today i'm pleased to
make a truly historic announcement in
our battle against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
[Music]
to help treat patients battling a
current infection
convalescent
[Music]
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
we provided 48 million to fund the mayo
clinic study that tested the
efficacy of convalescence
nobody that's a leader would not do what
i did
and i know there's a risk there's a
danger but that's okay
[Music]
i just left walter reed medical center
and i learned so much about a virus
don't be
afraid of it you're going to beat it we
have the best medical equipment don't
be afraid of it feel great like better
than i have in a long time
be afraid of it i didn't feel so good
don't be afraid of it you're gonna beat
it we have to put on a virus
don't be afraid of it and now i'm better
maybe i'm immune i don't know be afraid
of it
don't let it dominate don't let it take
over your life
be afraid of it don't let that happen
you're the greatest country in the world
afraid of it as your leader i had to do
that i knew there's danger do it but i
had to do it
but don't let it dominate your lives get
out there
be careful we have the best medicines in
the world
and it all happened very shortly and
they're all getting approved
and the vaccines are coming momentary
[Music]
all right uh wow enough of that we have
too much going on today to just play
songs all day we are standing by
for a press briefing with the biden
campaign
it is unclear as of right now number one
when it will be number two if this is a
joe biden briefing or if it is others
but we are standing by for that we do
have breaking news
at this time i can report to you
something that i tweeted hours ago
um the associated press has called
the state of wisconsin for joseph
r biden jr now putting joseph
22 electoral votes from securing
victory and nothing is guaranteed
everyone must vote i guess i can stop
saying that since voting is done
um but we are now we are really now
getting into the thick of it and we're
going to be going through a number of
these different elements i am going to
be updating my map
as well momentarily but what you need to
understand
is there is a completely separate
narrative a story that is being told to
you right now
by those who want to believe that
everything is
fine other than trump was robbed of an
election by evil socialist
marxist anarchists other than that
everything's going fine
donald trump now talking about sending
his children to philadelphia where rudy
giuliani is going
trump talking about and filing a lawsuit
in michigan
which is still uncalled trump paying for
trump is fundraising like crazy
because recounts are expensive and he's
doing a recount in or wants a recount in
wisconsin which we will talk about
and then in addition to that where i've
got to get all of my elements organized
here otherwise we're going to have a
tough time
also arizona
even though the ap has called it the
trump campaign insisting that they will
win
arizona by about 75 000 votes
currently they are losing by 94 000
votes so we're going to talk about
all of these things my view right now
after spending last night with you guys
by the way record setting night
perfect night i will talk to you guys
about it in a moment
we have data and data now from it um i
think the associated press is being
extraordinarily responsible the
associated press as you can see
has not called nevada has not called
michigan is not called pennsylvania
north carolina or georgia they haven't
even called alaska actually
even though alaska appears as though it
will be irrelevant in the final calculus
um i think when the associated press
calls it
it's good essentially and i think that
we can trust that now before we move on
to the specifics i do want to point
you guys to some interesting numbers
donald trump again has lost the popular
vote
not by a little but by a lot and donald
trump won the electoral college with 304
electoral votes in 2016
despite losing the popular vote by a
couple of points
and indeed now joe biden has received a
record number of votes
first of all most people voted for biden
biden is over 50 that's number one
number two
70 million votes
for joseph r biden jr never
has a candidate received 70 million
votes in american history and of course
as our population grows absolute numbers
don't necessarily mean what someone
all the normal caveats but understand
that that is that is absolutely massive
the electoral college needs to go trump
wouldn't be president were it not for
the electoral college at all
and we would be talking about nothing we
would be talking about other things
right now
right now it is a margin of about 2.8
million votes a similar margin to i
believe what hillary clinton
won by maybe hillary was more like 2.6
but this is going to be a big margin
because remember
we're waiting on atlanta we're waiting
on philly
we're waiting on um pittsburgh we are
there's all sorts of numbers that we are
still waiting for look at california
guys
we only have two-thirds of the vote in
from california
this is going to be a historic popular
vote win for joseph r biden jr
and maybe he will also become president
because of our system
one is not guaranteeing of the other now
i'm not going to do it today because
we're dealing with the news of today and
trying to figure out who is going to be
the next president
but i don't want it to be lost on
anybody
that you know as as an independent
progressive
who has never been a democrat there are
some
serious problems for the democratic
party going forward
a lot of why donald trump got 67 million
votes
is idiotic people it's people who they
see a pandemic poorly dealt with
they see a disastrous economy they see
police
anti-police brutality protests poorly
dealt with they recognize that they're
poorly dealt with but they still vote
for
trump anyway and i discussed that on
today's podcast
but the the numbers for hispanic voters
for biden
a win or lose the electoral college the
numbers are a disaster the democratic
party needs to figure out what the hell
is going
on to borrow a phrase from donald trump
i have some ideas
and we're going to be talking about that
in all likelihood
democrats are not going to take the
senate
as you can see right now um
it is not looking like democrats are
going to take the senate although
we still have to wait even in the house
as of right now it is going more in the
direction of republicans republicans
have flipped five seats and and
so far have gained five while democrats
have lost five so
if indeed you know i i am the ultimate
realist with you guys
if indeed joseph r biden jr becomes the
next president of the united states
eking out a win that is nothing like
what the
538 projections were if biden wins it
will look like
my projection and i'm not patting myself
on the back many people
believed that this was not going to look
like 350 electoral votes for biden
if he squeaks it out there are some real
questions to talk about you know as far
as the senate remember i've been saying
for years
um i don't think democrats take it in
2020 i think the opportunity for
democrats is in 2022
there was a period there where it looked
like maybe democrats could take it
it doesn't look like it's going to
happen so all of these issues are issues
we're going to talk about but
for the time being we are standing by
for joe biden
we are monitoring all sorts of different
election broadcasts although really
the big news right now is that wisconsin
has been called
for joe biden let's transpose
over to my 270 to win website this is
the map let me make sure
248 214 248 214. okay
so let me just play the scenarios out
for you at this point in time
let's just give alaska to trump because
eventually trump's going to get it i
don't see any point
in keeping it um at some point it's
going to go to trump
at this point if biden gets michigan
alone it's not enough
okay so biden needs michigan
and nevada that's one possibility
alternatively if he gets neither
pennsylvania alone
is also not enough okay
and then again we still have questions
about north carolina
it it's not looking good in north
carolina
um but north carolina and nevada
would get us to 269 but if trump were to
get
the others we have that tie i think a
tie is extraordinarily unlikely i think
it is extraordinarily unlikely
um right now as many of you are pointing
out nevada is looking blue it is
um half a point no votes have been
reported
in the last many hours we don't know
when we are going to know that so
nevada going blue would certainly be
good but again with our currently
outstanding
um there are still people by the whoops
sorry there are still people saying
that georgia could even ultimately go to
joseph biden i just don't see it i don't
see it it would be interesting
now there are people talking about
nebraska two
oh what is going on in nebraska too i
actually don't know what is going on in
nebraska too but
we have the same count 248 to 214.
we have nebraska too how is it being
counted here
oh what's going on sounds like some
strange noises outside
um four oh so there is one
oh interesting so i'm off then
if we give one to biden
one republican two democrat yeah so but
now i'm off now i'm off because
um 248 to 214
now i have 249 to 216. what oh trump got
one in maine
as well okay so trump gets one in maine
there we go now i'm at 248 to 217
248 242 oh and that's alaska okay
because i have alaska fair okay
so now we're we're lined up 248 to 214
248 to 214. alaska will eventually go
red
perfect okay perfect now now we've got
it so
um again the point is
um with with michigan and nevada biden
wins he doesn't need georgia north
carolina or pennsylvania that's the
point so there are basically a number of
paths forward this would be one path
forward
if michigan and nevada were to go red
of course biden could win with
pennsylvania and north carolina
if he doesn't get north carolina but
does get pennsylvania and michigan
that's a win if he doesn't get michigan
but he gets pennsylvania and nevada
that's a win
so there's a whole bunch of different
scenarios here
none of which are guaranteed now why
aren't they guaranteed as we are getting
close to hearing from joe biden
they're not guaranteed because it is
lawsuit hell that is starting right now
trump campaign has
holy [ __ ] there's 50 000 people watching
i thought we'd have like 5 000 viewers
right now
holy [ __ ] okay sorry that actually
distracted me
uh the trump campaign has filed a
lawsuit in michigan
now what's fascinating about the
michigan lawsuit is they don't seem to
understand that
biden's ahead so if you stop counting
right now
biden wins i don't know what they're
thinking there but they are desperate
meanwhile donald trump declared victory
yesterday
remember this so we won there we lead by
76 000 votes with almost nothing left
and all of a sudden everything just
stopped
this is so we'll fact check this thing
stopped because they stopped counting
ballots overnight
on the american public it's an
embarrassment to our country
so he's already claiming fraud we
were getting ready to win this election
frankly
we did win this election and of course
the crowd cheering
but there was no election to take a
victory lap on at this time
there was no election to take a victory
lap on at this time so we've got that
we've got this we also have rudy
giuliani who says on route to
philadelphia with legal team
massive cheating trump up by 550 with 75
counted will not let philly democrat
hacks steal it they are also reportedly
deploying eric trump and others to
philadelphia so
anybody thinking trump is going to go
quietly
he is not going to go quietly he is not
going to go quietly
um okay what else wow
things are just exploding i'm getting
text messages that's rude i should
definitely silence my phone we're going
to hear from the biden campaign very
very soon
if you're just joining us again just to
reset the big news is that
wisconsin has gone for joe biden joe
biden now with
seven or eight different likely
combinations which could get him to 270.
we don't know yet everything must be
counted in the meantime
um let me take a look at what's going on
in pennsylvania
in pennsylvania right now trump is plus
7.7 if you look at
philadelphia they've still got 39
of the philadelphia vote to count do the
math
okay biden's winning roughly four
to one in philly and 40
of the vote is still out there that is
unilaterally could reverse the results
pittsburgh
74 counted biden winning by 11.
that could be another 70 or 80 000 vote
margin that disappears
when pittsburgh is completely counted
this is a real thing okay this is math
and trump
i guess we should look if biden's not
speaking yet we can briefly look trump
is losing it on twitter
trump is absolutely melting down on
twitter now i'm going to tell you
if trump wins these tweets are going to
be really disturbing
if trump loses we are going to print
these out and i'm going to frame them
and they're going to be up here for the
next four years
trump's tweeting agit trash as i call it
and it is being flagged by twitter as
deceptive okay
trump tweeting last night i was leading
often solidly in many key states in
almost all instances democrat run and
controlled
then one by one that's how we count the
void the votes donny one by one
one by one they started to magically
disappear as surprise
ballot dumps were counted very strange
and the postal posters got it completely
wrong what's happening is they're
counting ballots
they're counting ballots trump then
again how come every time they count
mail-in ballot dumps trump really
obsessed with dumps in these tweets
they are so devastating in their
percentage and power
of destruction because the early vote
was overwhelmingly against you it's very
simple
it's very very simple um
what is this all about this is just
garbage trump tweeting to a matt walsh
post
which then led to some other tweet which
has then been removed i mean it's
completely crazy
it's a rabbit hole of nothing you just
go in it's like russian dolls you just
go into the smaller and smaller ones
and there's nothing there they are
finding
biden votes all over the place so bad
for
our country well they're counting votes
they're counting votes can you imagine
can you imagine this
and then what else from trump here's
another misleading one
they're working hard to make up a 500
000 vote advantage in pennsylvania
um all of these are getting flagged we
are winning pennsylvania big but the
secretary of state announced there are
millions of ballots left to be counted
if you are for democracy if you hear
there are millions of ballots to be
counted you say
[ __ ] let's count them millions of
ballots to count what
let's see we could throw them out we
could file a lawsuit so that we don't
count them
or maybe we count the ballots like that
that's where my mind goes when i hear
there are millions
uh to be counted it's absolutely
ridiculous
okay we are standing by for joe biden
welcome to everybody watching on youtube
twitch and facebook i was really not
expecting a big crowd today
um i just thought i would kind of get us
all caught up on what's going on
but we do have 65 000 viewers on youtube
we do have 2500 on facebook and 3 500
delightful twitch users
all here and we are about to hear from
the biden campaign
momentarily um a few thank yous i do
want to say thanks to peggy calhoun
who's new member number one today at
joinpakman.com
also thanks to adam rood as new member
number two
brian greene is number three and
benjamin devry's
is new member number four uh we also
are counting twitch subs
and we are at uh we started at 1672
we're at 1676 which puts this at eight
very much appreciate it now i want to
congratulate you guys
i want to congratulate you guys i have
stunning
data from last night's stream
okay this is just you i wish i had data
from twitch and facebook but i don't
we were 16th youtube wide
all you think about the all of the
people covering the election
last night we were 16th across youtube
globally with our stream
1.4 and climbing million total views of
that stream
when we add in twitch and facebook we
estimate we had between one and a half
million and two million views for our
broadcast
yesterday unbelievable numbers the only
independent news outlet that beat us
yesterday was the young turks they
streamed all day
they have 5 million subscribers not a
surprise
we beat everybody and then otherwise you
have you know these 100 million dollar
production
outfits like nbc cbs news
we were right with them unbelievable
numbers absolutely unbelievable and by
the way you guys see this right here
this is my favorite youtube says we only
got
33 subscribers from yesterday's stream
do you know why that is it's because you
guys broke the subscribe button
so many people hit subscribe during
yesterday's youtube stream
that you triggered a spam alert where
youtube thought
there can't possibly be thousands of
people signing up for david pakman right
now
we're gonna just cut it and we'll count
the bet they're gonna be counting these
after the fact
you had to get the subscribe in on
election day these are going to be
counted after the fact
so we're expecting anywhere from five to
fifteen thousand
subscribers from yesterday they're still
counting these
a much very analogous in fact to what's
going on with the election
so thank you very very important i mean
just unbelievable numbers
and allegations that we were using bots
of course continuing to pour in but i
completely
uh uh deny that no bots whatsoever were
used
and by the way it's crazy every time
youtube looks for subscriptions
they're finding a thousand here they're
finding a thousand there it's crazy and
the recounts are being demanded
oh one other thing i want to mention i
haven't seen any of this yet
but i've been getting emails saying
david have you seen
that cultural critic and arbiter of
ideas dave rubin
is playing up the fraud angle that biden
stole it
have you seen that tim poole is playing
up the fraud angle i haven't seen any of
that
i don't pay attention to those guys i
have no clue what on earth they are
talking about
someone sent me a screenshot of a tim
pool video from a few weeks ago saying
uh there will be a trump uh landslide or
something
i don't know what's real and what's not
i don't pay attention to those to those
guys whatsoever so i would not be able
to comment on that because i have no
clue what it is that they're saying
um okay let's get to
people asking if i'm going to go through
the the scenarios
i already did but i see that we have a
lot of people joining last minute so
okay
let me just do it again real quick um
this is the map right
now wait no this is not the map what am
i missing here
oh pennsylvania jeez okay this is the
map right now
we've given trump alaska because i
believe he's going to get it wisconsin
called for joseph r biden jr so
the possibilities are biden gets
michigan
and nevada okay michigan and nevada gets
him over the edge doesn't need any of
these three
um if he doesn't get michigan but he
does get nevada pennsylvania would also
work
or north carolina would get him to 269
which is a problem or uh georgia would
get him to
270. so that's another possibility um
if he doesn't get nevada but gets
michigan and pennsylvania that would
work
michigan and north carolina would work
michigan and georgia would work
if he didn't get michigan georgia and
pennsylvania would work
or georgia and north carolina or
north carolina and georgia so i think
what what we're saying is
two of two of almost any of these
other than if nevada is one of them you
probably need three that's the important
thing if nevada's one of them you
probably need three
any of those combinations would get joe
biden to 270
and that's really what matters
that's really that's really what matters
so it is very very close
if you had followed my map you know i do
think that we are going to
we're going to do a sort of post-mortem
on polling at some point when
we can't do it until we have all the
numbers but
i was warning people you know 538
predicts 350 for biden
5 30. oh thanks david chadman for the 10
subs
princeton predicts 355 for biden
i was getting attacked and i'm not i'm
not
playing victim i'm just saying people
disagreed with me i was getting attacked
for being wrong i'm a big boy i can
handle it a saying david
biden's going to run away with this this
is going to be easy why are you so
why are you telling people the polls may
be overstating the lead why why why why
well this is why this is why this is why
my map didn't even give joe biden 300
electoral votes we are seeing why
um okay anyway but yeah everybody was so
mean to me when i said vote everybody
was
mean come on guys i'm not trump
we can i can handle it jesus
okay let's get to a couple of
super chats that i want to get to
um let me just i'll just do a couple
because these are just flying
in how is it possible to just count up
one by one this
arabic sounding arithmetic is a zionist
plot come on david don't be a shill
what an attack on math emmanuel says you
deserve it all david very objective
informative content thanks for keeping
us up to speed
ritualistic mystic says as a trans man
living in america i find it hard to want
to stay in this country
i understand we're so behind the times
for a developed country yeah the world
is laughing
i mean listen if if donald trump
loses this election um electorally
the world is still going to know we have
67 million trumpists here
okay and that's an embarrassment and we
will talk about that i actually
did a piece today on my podcast
about how to understand
the 67 million votes for trump and it's
very easy to say
these are merely stupid people or these
are
merely bad people or merely ignorant
people or merely religious extremists
there are instances of all of that but
the piece i did on today's podcast which
all of you
if you don't get my daily podcast
i don't know what you're doing on the
podcast
um i explained that to understand the
trumpist mentality
ignorance aside malevolence aside all of
that stuff aside
you have to understand that they believe
they are at war
in a literal sense okay and from
that comes uh comes a lot
of understanding about um how and why
it is impossible to reason with a lot of
those
uh individuals people asking oh people
asking how many hours of sleep i got
last night
yeah i actually posted um speaking of
following i don't know how many of you
follow me on instagram
you should really follow me on instagram
for coffee pictures and
espresso pictures voting videos and all
sorts of different things
but i did post relatively early this
morning
here we go again my cappuccino i never
claimed to be able to do latte art i
just claimed to know how to
dial in the espresso my claims about
latte art have never been
significant um back in front of the map
i was probably
um we went off air at midnight
and i uh you know had a snack
looked at twitter read a bunch of my
i'm reading a great blake crouch book
right now i was probably asleep by 1 15
and i planned to sleep into 8 30
actually
it just was not possible i uh was roused
at about 7
15 7 30 and i was just starting to
wonder what was going on so i was up
i was up at that point but that was that
was my night
okay oh people shocked that i'm
left-handed yeah
i control the mouse with my left hand
that's true not
recursion by blake crouch it's actually
i i have read recursion recursion by
blake crouch is fantastic
dark matter is fantastic blake crouch by
the way a friend of the show
he's been on the show um i've been
working my way through some of blake
crouch's
older sort of suspense horror type stuff
uh and i encourage you to check it out
he's got some really good stuff i'm
reading the
the sequel to the first andrew thomas
uh series so to speak recursion
is a fantastic book fantastic fantastic
book
okay we are standing by we think we're
going to hear from joe biden but we
don't actually know
we don't actually know so we're going to
wait
um a few other super chats coming in
let's see
david i'm happy you're sounding more
optimistic today you scared me last
night with your panicked outlook
listen so last night when we signed off
i was at 35
panic by the way moderators on youtube
we've let's do something about these
posts where it's like
a hundred of the same uh uh
image these are not good with what we've
got going on with 60 000 people watching
we really can't have that stuff clogging
up let's see if we can do something a
little bit about that
um my i think my panic level has gone
from about 35
to 25 um i think
oh did i close out at 60 yesterday maybe
i did anyway i'm at like 25
panic right now i see a path and it's a
very specific path
let's just see if we have any updated
numbers michigan now at 98 percent
uh biden up 0.6
pennsylvania 84 percent
and the margin has started to close a
little bit maybe
we're still waiting oh some more vote
this is important
we have more vote coming in from nevada
we just got about eight percent more
and um it is still just a
very slim margin for joe biden so we're
keeping an eye on that
there are still some folks holding out
hope in georgia
the margin in georgia with 95 reporting
is 1.6
and then north carolina with 94
reporting the margin is 1.4 so trump
can't afford to lose
um any of those at this point he can
lose one in theory
people asking my reaction to the um
speech from trump claiming victory at 2
am we just looked at that nevada's done
for the day that's good to know
we just looked at that i i predicted on
monday
you know i got crushed for that
prediction as well on monday i said
trump will step up to a podium if he
even has a path to victory and claim
victory and that's exactly what he did
i'm accepting apologies via telegram
not the website like actual telegrams if
you want to send me a telegram i would
appreciate them
um okay a couple of other
super chats will the left realize
they are at war and respond in kind
interesting leo says if trump loses do
you believe there will be peaceful maga
protests or angry maga riots and if so
what would be the law enforcement
response
listen trump is already playing up this
thing that it was stolen that they're
stealing his votes that they're going to
get their votes with lawsuits and
recounts
so i believe that there is a real risk
of trumpist
armed violence i i believe it's a
serious possibility
jacob says we need to stop counting
votes in michigan so we can know who won
already democracy
can't be delayed also we need to recount
all the votes in wisconsin democracy is
slow and we need to be patient
will it be hard for trump to push these
messages at once
well anybody who has common sense
realizes the absurdity of those messages
but um a lot of people aren't realizing
that and donald trump is simultaneously
saying
we just have to stop counting in certain
places and we've got to keep counting in
certain places
and we need lawsuits and we need
recounts and we need rudy giuliani i
don't know if you saw earlier
uh we looked at this tweet rudy posting
enroute to philadelphia with legal team
massive cheating massive cheating says
rudy
let's see if he's posted anything else
no that's his last post
um so so there is that just unbelievable
unbelievable stuff
let's see what is going on cbs nothing
of particular interest
and nbc nothing let's listen in a little
bit
oh it sounds like there's nothing to
listen into interestingly enough okay
let's take a look also at abc news
and see what is going on there that was
cbs let's see what's going on with abc
news
in the former vice president's favor now
we could have
a wait of several days before we get all
of these results terry diane
because they are going very very slowly
they didn't start counting until
yesterday
they said they thought they could count
about 30 000 mail-in votes an hour
it turned out to be about 10 000. uh so
we're sort of hanging out in
pennsylvania camped out and
so we're waiting there people said i had
the wrong nbc stream let me see is this
the right one
ah here is the right okay let's listen
to what's going on here donald trump
with the advantage there the trump
campaign announcing that they would be
calling for
a recount immediately something that
they can do when
the vote is within one percentage point
right now it is
under one percent that separates the two
even as we have announced that joe biden
is the apparent winner in that state and
then within the next 30 minutes
now less than that about 20 minutes from
now in pennsylvania specifically
in philadelphia we are going to hear the
next sort of
um effort by the trump campaign great
lewandowski the former campaign manager
i mean disgusting but i'm glad that
it'll happen on stream so we can take it
all in together giuliani
the president's personal attorney will
all be there for a news conference to
take place
in the next half hour i'm told um by
folks
in the campaign that they are focusing
on what they describe as ongoing
election issues yeah the issues are
they're counting ballots
they're complaining about what he
described as massive cheating
in that state again there's no evidence
of any cheating taking place
in fact in pennsylvania they are still
counting the ballots that are
outstanding don't you understand that's
the cheating continuing to count ballots
that's the cheating that they're talking
about
any ballots that were postmarked by
yesterday election day
if they arrived by this friday so within
72 hours of election day
they would be legal and they could be
counted
those in the trump campaign say they are
demanding that the folks in philadelphia
play by the rules for the moment
those are the by the rules has said
otherwise
again the supreme court standing by them
so that's where things stand
right now from the campaign's purposes
the president as you've noted
last night effectively declaring victory
falsely obviously and prematurely but
now
they're sort of conceding that that's
not the case that they can't claim
victory changing their language at least
the campaign
they won but they need lawsuits and
press conferences
and certain places to stop counting and
certain places to keep counting but only
if they're trump votes and if not they
don't
they've won oh they're sure that they've
won but they're going to need to invoke
force measure
let me get up to speed on new members we
have just added an additional 19 website
members which puts us at 27 today
and also on twitch adding
uh 40 more which puts us at
67 delightful number delightful number
and so the schedule guys as of right now
is we're expecting to hear from some
uh motley crew of trumpists including
i'm guess i'm hearing some combination
of
rudy giuliani eric trump
um maybe ivanka i don't know if jared
kushner has been dispatched to
philadelphia
corey lewandowski we heard i don't know
but we're going to be hearing from a
bunch of people from trump uh uh in
philadelphia as well where they're i
guess going to be making the case that
there's cheating i don't know it's it's
the peanut gallery exactly right that is
absolutely exactly right
patrick asking whether i got any sleep
yes i did i got about six and a half
hours of sleep i posted to my instagram
this morning my cappuccino
and i was right back at it in front of
my my computer looking at the map
um and a lot of other interesting things
for people who are new
to to these streams i did post video
voting as you can see
there it is full insertion of my ballot
into an official
dropbox and then just walking right off
screen
i actually sent this to my doctor he
said he had never seen anybody
vote like this before he said it was
really something else
and uh boom just right in and off
mask nose clip strongly in
and uh it was a great day it was really
really a great day so that
those are the kinds of things on my
instagram if you want a little bit of a
break from
the constant tragedy of our current
situation
um okay let me get to some other super
chats because there are lots of people
who want to weigh in
kristen says as a canadian i'm shook at
the orange man
and even more at the americans who vote
for him
of course i share those sentiments i
share those sentiments
mark says much respec respect from saint
therese quebec
canada city just north of montreal
sounds lovely
joshua says per the new york times the
trump recount in 2016
only yielded him 131 more votes let him
count
it'll take weeks fair
fair onkit is asking my take on mitch
mcconnell's statements today
i actually didn't see them
i don't know what mitch mcconnell said
so i would be unable
to comment on that there is more
activity happening and more hijinks so
it looks like soon
something is going to happen here let me
see what folks are saying over on twitch
i don't want to miss a second of what's
happening there chive
has resubs for 14 months says 14 months
feels like yesterday when
cnn thought they owned the democratic
debate rights well said
well said lazy titan via twitch says
fingers crossed for biden
in the uk the weebs says
just to remind you you said sixty
percent panic that's right yeah
so we got to i was at 60
panic when we ended yesterday i'm back
down to about 20 25
i think that's an appropriate level of
panic at this point in time
and uh until the numbers change
i think that's where we're going to do
it now it looks like they're bringing
out
a second lectern and we have now lost
signal altogether
we've been standing by on this stream
for a while and we have now completely
lost the signal so we will go elsewhere
and see what else is going on
um waiting for both the biden campaign
and some delegates of the trump campaign
in philadelphia
so we're expecting a lot of different
things coming up very very soon
um let's see here
you know i think that i don't i don't
like this super chat
um we're gonna remove it i think it's
referring to a group that is uh
white supremacist group so we're gonna
remove that ankit says mitch mcconnell
said all votes need to be counted and
states decide
presidential election not candidates
well if that's what he said then he's
absolutely correct
no doubt about that no doubt about that
rockwell says biden underestimated the
uneducated white male boat sinking
made in china trump flag flying campaign
bus intimidation vote dammit joe
that's true that vote is bigger than joe
biden conceded
that's absolutely true daniel says david
if biden wins republicans hold the
senate democrats have the house how can
we avoid a classic 2020 2010 gridlock
we can't and that's exactly what i'll be
talking about later this week
we essentially can't dc says what's the
deal with recounts have there ever been
recounts with vastly different outcomes
well
you know you you look at florida in 20
in 2000 and the fact that the the
recount was
stopped remember the recount was stopped
in florida
and you wonder you wonder um but let's
see what happens
in wisconsin this time around let's see
what we have
here from abc news to election day so
um it's something that was on the minds
of everyone here and also
this is a state that is very divided so
in those blue areas in milwaukee in
in green bay in madison mass adherence
seems to be something that people don't
have an issue with but you go to other
parts of the state
and we've seen this over the last few
weeks
people don't believe they should be
forced to wear mass
there have been several lawsuits that
have come against the governor for his
mask ordinance and other
uh precautions restrictions that he's
tried to put in place here to control
the spread of coronavirus so
the pandemic very much on the minds of
everyone here and still a massive
massive problem
and wisconsin like several other states
right now really doesn't seem to have it
under control just yet
diane all right alex perez and wisconsin
yeah remember another hundred thousand
cases of coronavirus roughly yesterday
hundred thousand cases more or less um
we have oh let's listen to uh senator
is this is this chris coons i'm i'm
forgetting who this is
because if the president and his
campaign continue to to cast doubt on
these results continue
to say there were they've been making
claims that there were uh
disenfranchised voters that there were
things happening in certain states that
we haven't been able to verify at this
point but but they're casting doubt
will that tarnish you know as we move
forward here will that make it harder
for the vice president if if he is
declared a winner
well if donald trump had a reputation as
a truthful man
who routinely said clear and
science-based and truthful things
about other matters it might be a
greater problem but we know that
president trump
almost daily says things that are wildly
untrue about things as important as the
pandemic in public health
about world relations about the size of
his own crowds about all sorts of things
he is just a serially untruthful man who
has great difficulty saying things that
are honest
senator can i ask you to pause and stay
with us for a moment i want to get back
to peter alexander at the white house
with a little bit of developing news
oh here we go pennsylvania i understand
peter important
that's exactly right as we noted there
will be a news conference taking place
in pennsylvania about 10 to 15 minutes
from now but we just received a
statement
from the trump campaign about the newest
actions the legal actions they're taking
and there we go
fight for the integrity of the most
important election in our lifetime right
now so at
issue here is the fact that as we noted
in that state
they can receive ballots that are
postmarked by yesterday election day
through this friday that those ballots
would be counted that was upheld
by the supreme court well now according
to this new statement from the trump
campaign the action they are taking they
are suing
to stop the counting of those ballots
right now they want to try to pursue
this
trump doesn't want ballots counted right
again i suspect the supreme court
to weigh in trump's strategy is stop
enfranchising people disenfranchise
people to win just as amy coney barrett
who is on the court and separately that
they are demanding access to these
voting locations in pennsylvania where
some of the
voting excuse me the accounting process
rudy wants to fish around for another
laptop from hell
in michigan so not clear that they have
yet filed suit but that they will be
filing suit in pennsylvania as well
again rudy giuliani the president
personal
attorney will be among those who has
developed rudy's got to get slapped
around
proverbially of course only a short time
from now
as we've been reporting they are looking
for any possible avenue to try to
claw back some of these states this is a
state where they have an advantage right
now but there is
i think 1.3 something million votes
still out there and if you look at the
math
particularly in the bottom right of that
screen those
counties around philadelphia the
expectation is that
a lot of those votes many of the mail-in
ballots yet to be counted they didn't
begin the process
of looking at them until yesterday that
those ballots
and the ones that they may receive in
the next several days so donald trump
filing suit filing suit as we continue
to wait for joe biden and the biden
campaign
to say something at some point soon
we're expecting to hear from them
we are still monitoring all sorts of
different streams and ballots being
counted but now we have
we are standing by for um really a
peanut gallery a who's who
of depraved dilapidated delusional
dunces
from the trump campaign that are going
to be telling us
we've got to stop counting ballots they
keep
finding ballots and counting them this
must
stop wait what what hold on
you find the ballots right okay
and then you don't count them right yeah
you don't count them you find them then
you throw them out
why i don't know it's after election day
and something something something the
mail i don't know
um this is not how you win on the merits
this is how you win with foul play okay
and so we're going to be watching all
this very closely now in the meantime
it should be noted that with 99
reporting
michigan which could be called today
michigan
could be called today um joe biden is
winning by 0.7
and as a reminder michigan alone does
not seal the deal for joseph r biden jr
but if he were to get michigan and then
nevada it's over
you can throw pennsylvania's results
into the hypothetical
would be nice but don't need it category
same with north carolina and georgia so
michigan we are waiting on right now and
it is getting
very close to full results some reports
that we could get the full results today
other results uh others uh suggesting
that it might not be
maybe until tomorrow so we just don't
know
um this isn't live right he was going to
fight
okay that's from yesterday just making
sure we're not we're not missing
anything okay good
um all right let's get caught up
uh new members we are now at 29
that gives us plus six
where does plus six put us though plus
six puts us
at 73 we are counting twitch we were at
16 55 we are now oh my god
1725 on twitch
1655 that's 45 670 that 70 puts us at
143
holy [ __ ] that is nuts let's go back to
a target of 304
since that's uh the number of electoral
votes trump won with
back in 2016.
uh very much appreciate all of that
support
we are standing by oh hey this is kyra
phillips i know her
she's super nice we we met at an event
once as they call it
right this is kira phillips i think can
anybody confirm
no i could probably tell from her voice
hold on put out this quote
the president threatened to prevent the
proper
tabulation of votes we are standing up
to the biggest and most comprehensive
legal effort
ever assembled this work could stretch
on
for weeks so i'm coming to you to ask
you to pitch
25 in to the newly formed biden
trump wants 25 bucks to stop the
counting can you guys imagine what a
disgusting
disgusting turn of events um
okay craig dunk says lawsuit in michigan
to halt ballot counting yeah
he's trying to stop ballot counting it's
very very simple
it's extreme there's no mystery as to
the strategy here
and uh i don't know what happened with
can somebody get me an update on the
biden event they were supposed to speak
at 2
30. it's almost 3 30 here in the east
and we've not heard from them does
anybody have an idea
anybody know
we're not sure i would love an update on
what's going on with the biden stuff
they said 15 minutes 10 minutes ago that
i thought that was the trump event
though
we'll have to keep monitoring all of
them at this point
uh very very crazy stuff that is going
on here
mark fillion says hey 58 000 new cases
but you were rounding the corner
yeah well it's only a partial day
actually today in terms of coronavirus
we have
um 58 000 but yesterday we had 94
000. guys 1200 people died of
coronavirus in the united states
yesterday and this is one of the things
i talked about with sam cedar which was
there is no connect there seems to be a
complete lack of connection
between understanding things that happen
and how our leaders relate to those
things and how if you don't like the
things that happen with a leader
you would change the leader that seems
to be missing
as a logical inference for a lot of
different people and meanwhile
they want to fire fouchy uh thanks for
all the subs and gifts i know i'm having
trouble keeping up with anything
squeal squalor goblin has gifted 10
subs on twitch and i i do appreciate it
i apologize if i don't thank everybody
there's just a lot
a lot a lot going on as we wait both
for joe biden and a trump uh cast of
characters we are expecting to hear from
the biden campaign and the trump
campaign all in the next 15 minutes
supposedly supposedly uh oh
okay so it was a biden legal defense
fund
that that makes sense if your opponent's
trying to stop the counting of ballots
with lawyers you need some money that's
for sure
yeah i thought they were reading um i
thought they were reading emails
from uh the fundraising fundraising
emails i've been getting from
trump which are just hilarious steward
says david why do so many depraved trump
sycophants flock to your chat is this a
case of pacman derangement syndrome
yeah i want to say i don't know why
they're flocking but i do want to say a
little something about that
um you know this is this is kind of a
weird thing but
fortunately i live in a state that is
somewhat
insulated from the depravity of donald
trump so while
with things like foreign policy
the whole country is affected with the
u.s being a laughingstock globally the
whole country is affected
climate you know climate pollution
doesn't respect
uh state borders in a lot of ways i'm
insulated from a lot of the things that
donald
trump does and the truth is that my
business
will do better if trump wins that's the
reality so it's funny when all of these
uh trump trump clowns show up and they
say david i can't wait to see you cry
and you're going to be
like you know the the the unfortunate
truth or fortunate whatever
is a lot of people may lose jobs if
trump wins
i expect that we will continue to grow
very quickly if donald trump were to win
that this really isn't
about me this is about other people it's
bad for the country it's bad
for people who have to go into a real
job you know i'm lucky enough not not to
have to do that
uh but it is absolutely absurd the
latest news is not only
are uh our um legal mechanisms
being proposed in philadelphia in
pennsylvania the trump campaign is now
filing a lawsuit in michigan to stop
counting take a look
democrats now by the way biden's winning
michigan
if you stop counting now biden wins
biden's winning and trump wants a
lawsuit to stop counting
anyone who wants to observe can have
access here
particularly to that adjudication
process that i was talking about that is
so critical here so what we've seen
today uh transparency is the name of the
game kate all right dasha burns for us
uh in grand rapids michigan dasha thank
you we'll take a quick break here
we continue with decision 2020 election
coverage right after this all right
so lawsuits lawsuits being filed there
very very strongly
this is trump yesterday it's not live no
need to cover it
we are standing by uh for a truck
in fact one thing i do want to do let's
just listen to this for a moment i want
to try to find
uh specific streams for this weird trump
event i figure
you know you can ask someone a thousand
times what they're voting for and they
can assess whether or not it's safe for
them to be honest
but once you're in front of you know a
polling location you can make your
decision the way that you
see fit and the comfort of privacy and i
think that you know for a lot of
democrats and for a lot of posters
they have to recognize that just because
you don't like a candidate doesn't mean
that
other people don't like that candidate i
think that's a big
indication and then two not to throw
shade at the industry
um but exit polls don't necessarily
tell you the same thing that the polls
okay
so i found a video which um this
uh trump event was scheduled for right
now it's scheduled for one minute from
now
so hopefully we will hear that at some
point relatively soon
we also are standing by for the biden
event
and we have cameras trained in a number
of different states ballots are being
counted in philadelphia
and other parts of pennsylvania um
donald trump is filing lawsuits
i guess let's let's reset if we can
because i see that there's a lot of new
people joining us
if you are by the way if you're joining
on youtube
please do me the favor of hitting that
subscribe button i would really
appreciate it it's free and you'll be
notified about future streams
if you're joining on twitch make sure
you're following me on twitch
the news over the last couple of hours
are that
first and foremost overnight both
wisconsin and michigan
shifted from red to blue wisconsin has
now been called for joe biden
and donald trump is demanding a recount
and has started fundraising for a
recount there
michigan michigan is very close to
counting
every vote but donald trump has filed a
lawsuit there
to stop the counting of votes even
though he's losing i don't fully
understand the approach
nevada is reportedly done counting for
the day
it's only noon in nevada i don't know
why the hell they're not continuing to
count but they're not
um and so far we today we got about
seven eight additional percent of the
vote there
and it remains a very slim margin for
joe biden
we then still have alaska counting votes
but
it's going to go to trump not going to
be a factor
pennsylvania
continuing to count in pennsylvania
right now with 84
reporting the margin is 6.5 it has been
shrinking although very very slightly
north carolina
nothing additional in north carolina
still a 1.4 percent margin there
and then georgia with 95 reporting
a 1.6 percentage point margin in georgia
so
really the focus is can biden get
michigan
can biden get pennsylvania can biden get
nevada
that would put them over and in fact we
can go to that map
if biden gets michigan and nevada it's
over
okay um if biden does not get michigan
but gets nevada and pennsylvania it
would be over
if he doesn't get nevada but he gets
pennsylvania and michigan it would be
over
if he doesn't get pennsylvania but he
gets michigan and north carolina
it would be over if he doesn't get
michigan but gets wisconsin which he
already has
uh north carolina and oh pennsylvania
sorry hold on if he doesn't get
pennsylvania but he gets michigan and
north carolina it would also be over so
i think you guys understand
uh kind of where we're going here of
these one two three four five states
remaining
essentially any two gets it unless the
two
are whisk are uh nevada and
i think it was hold on nevada and north
carolina
would put him at 269. so nevada north
carolina would put him at 269.
any other combination of two states puts
joseph r biden jr at 270.
so we are standing by for all of that
information
oh beautiful this is the trump event let
me explain to you guys what we have
going
on here because this is gonna oh it
looks like uh police escorts are
arriving
this is going to be maybe
maybe one of the probably short of trump
declaring a false victory last night
what you're about to see here is going
to be a real treat for the history books
we're expecting some combination this is
philadelphia
we're expecting some combination of
rudolph giuliani
eric trump not known as the smart one as
we lose the signal
maybe jared kushner corey lewandowski
expected to be here
they're going to show up and tell us why
uh i guess why philadelphia why
pennsylvania's fraud
or something i don't even really
understand what exactly they are going
to tell us
we've just lost the feed uh we are
waiting to get it back
and we are also waiting for a biden
event
which was supposed to have started a
little while ago so hopefully this feed
will come back very soon we're going to
keep an eye on it
and we're keeping an eye on another uh
uh series of uh of streams
so we we will see that momentarily let
me get updated numbers as far as our
big membership day we are now at
plus seven on website memberships
putting us at 150
1758 is an additional 33
on twitch which puts us at 183. yeah
as i know that we have a lot of new
people who have found us
over the last 24 hours thanks to
yesterday's election results live
stream and even and even this stream
uh i i love that you're here i hope you
continue to check out our clips we do
clips every day and live streams
many days we are mostly funded
independently
okay so the best way to do this is just
go to my website joinpakman.com and grab
a membership this is not a lot of money
oh oh oh hold on a second what am i
talking about
we have a new coupon code okay
we have a new coupon code and this is if
there's any attorneys general
or law enforcement officers in the room
get them out all right because we are
now past the 2020 election
and i am considering this a fresh start
i have a new coupon code this is um
a heretofore unannounced
okay fresh start
this is you know red alert drudge
siren gif uh fresh start
is 70 off we've never had a coupon code
like this
okay if trump thinks he can just stop
voting
law has gone out the window so i am
offering an
illegal discount okay i'm kidding that
it's illegal some people actually think
some people actually write to me they go
are these discounts really illegal like
what which states are they illegal in
it's a joke guys just a joke it's just a
joke but in all seriousness
i would love it if you grabbed a
membership on my website
it comes with great perks it feels good
and the coupon code fresh start this has
never been announced okay you guys are
these
you 80 000 people are the first to ever
find out about this
will save you 70 it is a lawless
stream with an incredible incredible
discount
and uh i i love that y'all are here okay
let me see what's going on as far
as uh
okay we're standing by for rudy giuliani
we're standing by for joe biden
both standing by and we expect to hear
ungodly immoral things at this press
briefing here
kind of a weird location to even do it i
don't understand what they're doing
i really don't i don't understand what
they're doing but they're going to
explain to oh eric trump's twitter has
something
eric trump twitter
let's see what eric trump is saying on
twitter apparently eric
trump has tweeted something about this
event we are anticipating
uh burning 80 trump ballots
okay we have no idea what that is
uh eric trump tweeting we have won
pennsylvania
okay i don't know what that's based on
we have one pennsylvania
i think we need to respond
uh yeah we're not seeing that we go so i
don't know do you guys think i should go
by the associated press or by what eric
trump tweets in terms of calling states
you let me know
which do you recommend
interesting um
okay you don't want me going by eric
that's fair okay
um okay now with eight okay so votes are
actually coming in in pennsylvania this
is important votes are starting to come
in
in pennsylvania and we are now at
according to the new york times trump is
plus 6.5 oh okay so
trump's lead has gone from 6.9 to 6.5
that's important 6.9
6.5 a slight reduction in the lead there
and according to the associated press
they are
at 6.4 okay so that's an even smaller
lead
it is starting to shrink a little bit it
is starting to shrink a little bit in
pennsylvania
and michigan still stuck at 99 reporting
all right that's very very interesting
so we're standing by for donald trump
here um
let's look at some other super chats
that are coming in
john says joe's got this bernie is
closer now
i don't know what that means everybody
knows eric trump is the end-all for all
things elections
yes a lot of people very much respect
the predictive prowess
of eric trump they have microphones up
already i don't really understand why
but it seems as though there's kind of a
commotion
starting here people looking around
let's listen to the sweet sounds of
[Music]
philadelphia
guy with a shopping cart coming by
what's in this shopping cart
boxes and boxes of something and
hopefully those aren't ballots can you
imagine
that wouldn't be so good um all right
yeah we'll wait we'll wait until this
event actually starts
okay new york time listen guys anybody
wanting me to look at those new york
times needles
i i just don't think that it's worth
anything because they're flapping back
and forth like you know a wet noodle in
the wind i i just don't know that we get
that much from
let's just count ballots i think that's
probably a better way to do it at this
point in time
um okay and oh did biden start let's see
no we still don't even know what's going
the biden event was supposed to be an
hour ago
it's conceivable that the biden campaign
is waiting to see this abortive fiasco
that we're about to witness before they
do their press briefing
the fact that so many cameras and boom
mics are coming over
tells me we might be getting close to
this aaron says nevada's leaning blue
and will be counting until
friday will biden claim victory before
then absolutely no idea
absolutely no idea as far as that goes
we just have to wait
um a lot of
shenanigans going on for sure super guy
says what can biden do without the
senate if he wins that's a question
for later that's a question for later
people telling me on twitch to check
c-span are you telling me to check
c-span's twitch i'm sorry c-span's
twitter
or c-span's youtube channel what am i
supposed to be looking at for c-span
if anybody wants to let me know i'm glad
to check it but i don't know
c-span twitch okay
twitter okay
uh oh people telling me that the coupon
code is not working on my website hold
on that can't possibly be
uh no people are signing up with it it's
absolutely working
it's absolutely working uh oh my god
there's 650 people on my website
that is insane no but peop the coupon
code is working really well
the coupon code's working very very well
i'm told that there is another
that the biden event pbs has the biden
event let's see if we can find that
um scheduled for okay so pbs
has the trump event but i'm looking for
pbs biden press briefing
and they have it
not finding it unfortunately
ah here it is scheduled for 17 minutes
from now very good
i always rather have an extra stream you
just never know
this is what's going on outside the
biden event and pbs says
we're 17 minutes from it and here we're
waiting for the trump event so a lot of
different things going on
um and we're just going to have to wait
we're just going to
have to wait because we don't really
know if they're trying to wait each
other out or what is going on
i really don't know okay update on
some of these numbers 122
would get us 14
shy of 100 is 86 which puts
us at 269.
oh my god and then twitch at 1769
puts us at 280. so that's
that's very very solid that's an
extremely solid number
okay other oh i've i was i've been told
updated michigan numbers let's take a
look
michigan numbers still 99
reporting oh the lead has jumped to 1.1
this is actually important let's see if
the new york times numbers
match that michigan
the michigan numbers don't seem to have
been updated yet
so there was about a 37 000 vote lead in
michigan
according to the associated press i have
to tell you the associated press has
just been absolutely spot on
they have a vote update they have now
joe biden leading by 1.1 theoretically
that puts it
outside of recount territory if it's
greater than one percent
the lead has expanded to 61 000 votes
this is very very good news out of
michigan now
the trump campaign has filed a lawsuit
to stop the counting of votes in
michigan
it seems stupid because you're losing
right now it seems if you're losing you
want to keep counting votes
but right now i don't know that they
have any other ideas so that's what
they're doing
and then the latest numbers from
pennsylvania have
shrunk the lead to 5.9 guys
every time pennsylvania updates the lead
shrinks
45 minutes ago the lead for trump in
pennsylvania was 6.9
15 minutes ago the lead in pennsylvania
for by
for trump was 6.5 and now another 15
minutes later the lead in pennsylvania
for trump is down to only 5.9 and
importantly
this is only with two percent more of
the vote being being counted
in the last 45 minutes really really
important okay v really really important
numbers there
let's see what the new york times has
now for pennsylvania
they still have it at the 6.5 i just
mentioned it seems the times is a little
bit behind where the associated press is
so these are really important numbers
really really important numbers
as we wait to hear some ex so
understand the scene that's going on
right now
trump jumps out to a lead in
pennsylvania and then we hear
last night they're not counting any more
mail-in votes until today
we look and philadelphia is only half
counted pittsburgh is only half-counted
we predict a lot of those are going to
go in the direction of biden
today philadelphia starts counting
ballots
and the lead for trump shrinks from 6.9
to 6.5 to 5.9
giuliani and eric trump and others
are literally rushing to the city of
philadelphia
to try to stop what is going on
this is what they're doing this is their
strategy
to try to win this thing it is like
nothing we have seen before
like nothing we have seen before um
okay
let me hear from a few of our folks
watching on twitch um
let's see messages that have come in oh
none of the recent twitch subs actually
have uh
said anything okay
right pennsylvania may not be necessary
that i i i think that's important just
to remind people
uh if you get michigan and nevada you
don't need pennsylvania you don't need
north carolina you don't need georgia
very important point
but right now you don't have michigan
and you don't have nevada
but even if if you get pennsylvania you
still need something else
but right now you have nothing georgia
and north carolina have not been called
as you can see here now people asking if
they're still
up in the air you know it depends what
you mean by up in the air
uh we are still at a 1.4 margin in north
carolina
we are at a 1.6 margin in georgia
um they're certainly not the most likely
paths for joe biden
nevada is done counting for the day is a
very important reminder
crowd really gathering here it looks
like people are starting to take
pictures let's see what's going on
[Music]
there's a ton of screaming but i don't
know if these are protesters or if the
actual participants in this event
have shown up it's not clear to me
watch your head
it sounds like i know i know people that
are just joining are like what the hell
is going on
um some trump campaign officials are
rushing to philadelphia
to argue i guess that all counting of
ballots should stop in pennsylvania
um and the reason they're doing that is
that with every every uh with every
tranche of absentee ballots counted
the lead for donald trump is shrinking
in pennsylvania and they're very very
panicked now what they may or may not
know
is that um if biden gets
michigan and nevada he doesn't even need
pennsylvania
but they're trying to deal with nevada
by filing a lawsuit there as well
so this is a trump campaign you know
guys
a lot of my predictions are trash i mean
a lot of my predictions are literal
trash that you can just throw out and
ignore
but i said on monday uh biden's not
getting 353 electoral votes
and biden is not looking like he's going
to get 353 electoral votes i said monday
that biden
that trump rather would go up to a
lectern and claim victory
even if he hadn't won that's exactly
what donald trump did last night
i said that trump would file lawsuits
and use lawyers and go to courts to try
to win
that is exactly what donald trump is
doing right now and it was no special
insight on my part
it was that they were telling us this is
what they were going to do
they said we can't allow this we can't
allow that and here's how we're going to
prevent it
so it was not uh you know i'm not
nostradamus here
or nostradamus whichever is your
preference
uh these were just very very um
you know they were telling us that this
is what they were going to do
all right okay um for people who are
joining
and wondering what the a plan is going
to be
for by the way i'm sure they're going to
clear out all these protesters before
giuliani and whoever else got here
for anybody who's wondering the
streaming plan for the rest of the week
i have no idea
it's just going to be dictated by the
news cycle more than anything else
so what i would suggest is uh if you're
watching on facebook give us a like if
you're watching on twitch
give us a follow if you're watching on
youtube uh give us a free
subscribe hit that i i need you
destroying that subscribe button
because then you'll be notified when we
go live more and more police showing up
so
it's conceivable something is going to
happen although we still really don't
know what
some of the boom mics are coming down
some of the cameras are now pointed at
different places we really don't know
who's showing up when they're showing up
and and
where they're going to show up from
we're also standing by for joe biden
at the top of the hour again we see a
motorcade
i guess we think that this is the biden
motorcade
arriving for this event um
but we saw this earlier it's really
unclear what is happening right now
let's see what the major networks are
talking about
stocks joe biden expected to give
remarks shortly we will cover that
and um wisconsin now
given of course to joseph r biden jr so
we're watching all of it
we're watching all of it i would love it
if sasha baron cohen showed up here
as one of his various characters i think
that that would really be amazing
that would be fantastic other super
chats that are coming in
if you scroll down the new york times
map it shows the course of percentage
changes very
nicely you can see pennsylvania closing
in okay let's take a look at that that
would be interesting to see
pennsylvania full pennsylvania results
um what's been reported absentee
state senate state house other races huh
i'm not seeing that
absentee ballots
do i have to do full race results
maybe it's here results by county
tra ah here it is oh yes okay very this
is this is a beautiful this is a
beautiful graph yeah that's interesting
so the lead got very big as they had
counted about 60
which is where they stopped yesterday
and then now it's just shrinking
shrinking shrinking that's very
interesting data
the latest update now has this
at a 5.5 the lead has shrunk again
guys we are still at 85 reporting
and the lead has now gone from 5.9 to
5.5
5.9 to 5.5 rudy giuliani
is driving in a vehicle right now
trying to get as quickly as he can you
know it's like a 50s cadillac with a
huge
uh he's trying to get to philadelphia
and the
the lead is evaporating as rudy giuliani
approaches philadelphia it's
unbelievable what we are seeing right
now
and that's why we're standing by for
this uh press conference very soon
and expecting to hear from joe biden
very this it's crazy what's going on
yeah rudy shouldn't even be driving he
really shouldn't
i completely agree with that paula
mccullough
says thank you for holding my hand
through this david always enjoyed your
content but this election coverage
has won me as a subscriber and a member
thank you
yeah toby points out by the time trump's
lawyers stopped the counting biden might
be in the lead hurry to philadelphia
that it's it's a it's a cartoonish
situation
with every 15 minutes trump
is closer to tied losing the edge
and they're trying to get there as soon
as possible
papa ra says glued to my tv
watching this drama unfold thinking of
all of you up here in canada
tim says let's not overlook the fact
that 66 million americans voted for a
wannabe authoritarian dictator don't
worry
we are not overlooking that fact we are
not overlooking that fact don't
don't worry about that love the imagery
of rudy writing to save the day
thanks david uh scotland for biden
checking in
okay biden people better get be hot on
trump's goons tails they should be
behind or in front of every step that
trump's thugs are trying
show force yes i agree
riots in michigan trump supporters
trying to break
into the place where they are counting
that can't be true
let's see michigan trump supporters
break into polling counting
um if people actually have a news
article about that tell me where to find
it
oh people are saying it is true oh my
god what uh
what twitter account can i find that
that's insane can somebody tell me what
in the twitter account i can find that
steven merchant hold on this is getting
crazy
patterson nbc okay let me look at that
twitter.com
patterson nbc
let's take a look steve patterson
let's see what steve has for us via
twitter
um large animated crush of stop the
count protesters trying to push their
way into tcf hall in detroit where
ballots are being counted they're being
blocked by guards
pizza boxes pushed against the wind wow
the group claims to be
poll or election challengers claiming
there aren't enough non-partisan
challengers
inside holy geez
we've got to retweet that uh okay
as trump files a lawsuit
to stop counting votes in michigan
stop the count protesters
are trying to
break in and wreak
havoc whoa
what a situation wow
it's it's starting guys it's starting
now are they are those people considered
violent protesters by police are they
going to get tear gassed and whatnot
because that would be pretty wild
okay standing by for joe biden
standing by for a trump event standing
by for joe biden
standing by for a trump event waiting on
both here
russell says nevada election officials
say they may update the results this
afternoon that would be great
that would be great um
we had gotten word that nevada was not
counting any more today
and indeed it appears that they are
going to
somehow we've matched our audience from
last night we're back up to 83 000
viewers on youtube unbelievable
i did not imagine we would we would beat
last night but
it is it is happening uh nothing new
from nevada yet but it would be great if
we got some data from them
latest numbers from pennsylvania still a
5.5 percent lead
for donald trump it has been tightening
titan tightening a little bit at a time
but still 5.5 plus 5.5 for donald trump
and the tightening is why we are
expecting to see some members of the
trump campaign here very soon we are
also waiting for joe biden i don't know
which of these events is going to happen
first
i can tell you which is going to be more
unhinged
but i can't tell you which of the events
is going to happen first
um oh and the margin in michigan i'm
told has also crept up
i'm still seeing 1.1 let's refresh and
see
still seeing a 1.1 margin in michigan
let's see if the new york times
has it differently
the new york times now has a 1.2 percent
margin margin in michigan so
michigan is starting to get away from
donald trump
starting to get away from donald trump
not quickly but when you're at close to
100 percent and michigan says they
expect to have everything counted today
or tomorrow
that is a big deal that is a really
really big deal
uh okay getting very close to hearing
from joe biden
scheduled for the top of the hour are we
there's no voice now right
no okay all right so we should be
hearing from joe biden very soon
blob says thanks for the hard work you
put into your channel every day you're
making a real and positive impact on
adding clarity
in journalism my family and i are huge
fans and long time supporters from
toronto thank you
william happy to be with us from the uk
oliver ashamed
that it is this close check my last chat
for a new member goal
suggestion uh okay
let's see where is it
if you get to 304 next should be 4 20 to
celebrate marijuana's victory yesterday
which now allows residents to get high
enough to forget they live in new jersey
on purpose
that's a brutal attack on jersey i don't
like that
we uh we appreciate all of our viewers
all of our viewers from jersey
um okay still standing by for
joe biden still standing by
for some trump henchmen
here in philadelphia who knows when they
will arrive
jan says if trump loses or jan he if
trump loses no it must be jan because
it's euros
if trump loses he will call his
supporters to the weapons to claim the
vote and protect their dictator what do
you think i think this will come
i hope not i'm scared of the violence i
am
uh aurelio says can you talk a little
bit about what could happen to the
pandemic relief package with a biden
presidency and a republican senate
obstruction is what i would predict but
let's wait let's wait on that let's wait
until we really know for sure
adam says greetings from the czech
republic rooting for you guys hang in
there wishing your country a peaceful
transfer of power
thank you liam says i can't believe this
is happening
feels like we're in a movie essential
says gary peters took the lead over john
james he may
save his senate seat from takeover i saw
that and that would be
absolutely huge that would be absolutely
huge
and we're hoping that it happens um
david what's your take on sharpie gate
in arizona a bunch of people
claiming voter fraud in arizona yeah the
claim was that some people were tricked
into using a sharpie which the machine
didn't read
from what i've read the machine read it
just fine so i i'm i'm
reading that it's a fake story a false
story
um let's see if we have biden yet
no everything just very delayed today
very very delayed um
cbs doesn't have anything for us nbc
doesn't have anything for us
and uh abc doesn't have anything for us
either
the two big events right now are these
two philadelphia with some trump
henchmen
and then a biden event in i actually
don't know where they are
does anybody know where the biden event
is
is it in delaware maybe i'm not even
sure
okay yeah we're not we're not exactly
sure
um okay twitch mods we've got a bunch of
people that need to get banned
twitch mods uh please be aware that
there is uh some trash happening
a lot of trash happening on twitch we do
need we do need a few ban hammers there
appreciate it jeremiah says whoa where
did that go
jeremiah says dave loved listening to
the show every day great to hear
non-biased news from someone
i could happily sit down and have a beer
with appreciate that
appreciate that tarouin says how can
people try to stop counting do they have
any legitimate legal argument for this
blatant attempt at voter suppression
we will see i never pretend to know what
courts will do
particularly when many of those courts
are run by
people trump selected i am noticing that
the trump people in both twitch and
youtube chat
are getting more violent in their
rhetoric including towards me
and i i worry that this is a sign
of what may be to come if trump insists
if trump keeps falling behind but
insists that he has won
i'm i mean it's just like just in my
chat the violent rhetoric has gone
completely out of control so i think we
all need to be very very uh
aware of that and planning uh on how to
stay safe
very very important very important
because they're getting very violent
we're seeing it we're seeing it even in
the chat michigan
uh still waiting on numbers from
michigan and pennsylvania nothing new
very very slow numbers coming in from pa
we also heard a rumor that there may be
more numbers coming out of nevada this
afternoon although we don't yet know
and then of course georgia and pennsyl
and north carolina we are
still waiting on extremely slow
extremely slow
uh there as we stand by for
both uh representatives of both
candidates will i ever be on love or
host
maybe austin and i dm all the time he's
actually a big follower of politics
and uh yeah we're we're very much in
touch
okay let me get an updated new member
count we are now at 247
that's another 125
which puts us at 405.
wow and then on twitch we're at 1799
which is another 83 which puts us
at 488 incredible
incredible uh let's go we can't even do
420 because we're already past it
we're already past it let's go back to
750
one member or sub for every dollar
that donald trump paid in federal taxes
during many years and if you're just
joining us we we had a very we had a big
event happen earlier
um we 2020 now as a coupon code is done
the 2020 election is over the 2020
coupon code is done
new coupon code did i spell it correctly
i did fresh start
70 off coupon code fresh start on my
website
70 percent off and over a hundred people
already availing availing themselves of
it which is incredible
um okay oh five okay we'll do 538 first
the new goal is 538 the number of
electoral votes yes indeed
let's turn the volume up here so we hear
if anything starts
and we'll keep the video here we don't
know when this is actually going to
start
if they don't start this soon it's
actually going to start getting dark on
the east coast
that's what's insane this trump event is
so delayed
that the sun is going to start setting
if they don't
actually start this event at some point
and it's insane that it still hasn't
started
uh what else loose is best president for
black people since abe lincoln
ten percent of the black vote yeah hey
that's more than eight percent
thanks for being you says about three
pandas jacob says it david if the map
stays the way it is and biden wins by
one should we worry about faithless
electors
uh yes but we will cross that bridge
when we come to it
i think that that's the way to keep calm
right now is
we only cross these bridges when we come
to them
biden going live yeah we know we're
monitoring it
we're monitoring it i have the audio
turned up so we should be able to hear
it
david love your work can you explain how
people can vote for the corrupt
republicans even though they were
exposed in their debate i have a segment
on today's podcast about that
for people who are just stumbling across
my channel
my main thing is actually not live
streaming it's doing a daily hour show
and you can get that podcast on itunes
stitcher
pandora spotify and all sorts of
different places and i encourage you to
to do that
put the show in your pocket if you're
someone who leaves your house right now
during the pandemic
um a great thing to do we are on all of
those platforms
and a big thank you to completed
defiance who has just gifted
50 subscriptions 50 twitch subs
have been gifted by completed defiance
an extremely extremely strong
situation pbs news is now covering the
biden event
uh cbs not yet nbc
not yet and abc
not yet but we are we are covering it we
are standing by
we are expecting to hear from joe biden
really soon and we're expecting a
propaganda event from rudy giuliani also
very very soon so a lot is
a lot is happening there um
what else do we have going on
did i yes people asking if i if i had my
if i had coffee this morning after the
long night i did
in fact i know that this is not the most
important thing
but if you follow me on instagram and
you really should
you would have seen my um failed latte
art cappuccino
in front of my computer this morning
bright and early
back at it um looking at the numbers as
you can see the numbers have changed
since oh the podcast is called the david
pakman show for people asking
um the numbers have already changed but
i was right back at it did get some
sleep
and a lot of coffee content slow-mo
elements of espresso really strong
crema game as you can see beautiful
crema in fact
uh and even insert insert visible during
some of these so a lot happening over on
uh
a lot happening over on on instagram but
in all seriousness
um yes we wrapped up at about noon
and then i'm sorry not noon midnight
wrapped up about midnight
i was asleep by about 1 15 and back at
the desk
not this desk my office desk at about 7
30.
okay biden is starting i am told
let's see if any of these feeds have
them
here we go thank you the press for being
here and thanking everyone else my
fellow americans yesterday
once again proved that democracy is
double audio hold on to this nation has
has been the heartbeat of this nation
for two centuries
and uh even in the face pandemic more
americans voted this election
than ever before in american history
over 150 million people
huge cast their votes i think that's
just extraordinary
and if we had any doubts we shouldn't
have any longer
about a government of by and for the
people
it's very much alive very much alive in
america
here the people rule
power can't be taken or asserted
it flows from the people and it's their
will
that determines who will be the
president of the united states
and their will alone not rudy and now
after a long night of counting it's
clear
that we're winning enough states to
reach 270 electors wow
it's huge that biden is saying this i'm
not here to declare that we've won
but i am here to report when the count
is finished
we believe we will be the winners
with all the votes counted we have won
wisconsin by 20 000 votes
virtually the same margin that president
trump won
that state four years ago true in
michigan
we lead by over 35 000 votes now 61 000
a substantially bigger margin and
president trump won michigan
in 2016. michigan
will complete his vote soon maybe as
early as the day
and i feel very good about pennsylvania
virtually all the remaining ballots to
be counted were cast by mail
it just tightened again we've been
winning
seven oh no it did percent of the votes
sorry by mail
in pennsylvania we've flipped arizona
and the second district of nebraska of
special significance to me
is that we've won with the majority of
the american people
and every indication is that the
majority will grow
we have a popular vote lead of nearly 3
million votes
true and every indication is that will
grow as well
indeed senator harris and i are on track
to win more votes than any ticket in the
history of this country
true that ever won the presidency and
vice presidency
over 70 million votes i'm very proud of
our campaign
only three presidential campaigns in the
past
have defeated an incumbent president
when it's finished
god willing will be the fourth this is a
major achievement
this is a major achievement and it's
been a long and difficult campaign
but it's been a more difficult time
for our country
we've had a hard campaigns before
faced hard times before so once this
election
is finalized and behind us it'll be time
for us to do what we've always done as
americans
to put the harsh rhetoric of the
campaign behind us
to lower the temperature to see each
other again
to listen to one another tweet to hear
each other again and respect and care
for one another to unite
to heal to come together as a nation
i know this notice he's not demanding
votes not be counted he's not accusing
anybody of fraud he's not saying
anybody's stealing anything
views are in our country on so many
things
but i also know this as well to make
progress
we have to stop treating our opponents
as enemies
we are not enemies wow what brings us
together as americans is so much
stronger
than anything that can tear us apart so
let me be clear
i we are campaigning as a democrat
but i will govern as an american
president
hey i just have to tell you guys i'm so
pleased with our moderators
someone in twitch chat just started
making bogus
cheating claims which are not found and
we're taking that very seriously
i went to ban them and a second before i
did one of our moderators already banned
them i love it precisely what i will do
i will work as hard for those who didn't
vote for me
as it will for those who did vote for me
now every vote must be counted
no one's going to take our democracy
away from us
not now not ever america's come
too far america's fought too many
battles
america's endured too much to ever let
that happen
we the people will not be silenced
we the people will not be bullied
we the people will not surrender
my friends i'm confident will emerge
victorious
but this will not be
my victory alone or our victory loan
it'll be a victory for the american
people
for our democracy for america this is
good
and there will be no blue states in red
states
when we win just the united states of
america
god bless you all and may god protect
our troops
now just for comparison guys here's
donald trump
last night okay hold on where where did
i have this
oh dear god where was it uh oh hold on
oh
no oh i don't have it anyway i was gonna
bring you trump claiming to have won
last night um very very well said by joe
biden
uh he didn't insult anybody it was a
conciliatory message of unity
um he did not claim victory but says he
believes that they have a path there and
that ultimately they will be victorious
um i mean just this this is what you say
you're not threatening anybody you're
not suing anybody you're not doing any
of that stuff
next we go to a planned event
involving the trump campaign trying to
stop the counting of votes
i mean it's you know it's
could this be any different could we be
dealing with any different of a
situation here
um and we are uh soon going to be seeing
that okay let me look at the latest
numbers out of
philadelphia whoa things got a little
crazy here let me go back to
all states wait alabama all states there
we go
the latest numbers in pennsylvania with
another
sliver counted are 6.83
the lead is now down to 5.3
this is again as small as the lead has
been
and in fact the new york times has this
very interesting thing
which one of our viewers told me about
which actually tells you
full race results how the lead has
changed over time
and look at that that is exactly what we
are seeing let me see if i can zoom in
on that a little bit phallic actually
it's interesting but it is
it is what it is i can't control that um
as you can see
as the ballot counting resumed this
morning
the lead has shrunk shrunk shrunk they
have it at 83 percent
in fact when you look at the associated
press data
they are at 86 reporting and the lead is
now just
5.3 so the that is a real change there
in terms of what we are seeing um
okay cnn
has just projected michigan for joseph
r biden jr michigan has been projected
for joseph r
biden jr let's see if anybody else is
doing so as well
um let me see if i can find us a cnn
live stream
cnn live stream uh even without i could
always log into my uh
it's a little risky but i could log into
my cable
and we could watch it that way but let's
just take a look at what we've got
cnn reportedly calling michigan let's
take a look
standing by for cnn tells you why we
make this projection right now
wow and watch this it's an impressive
win in the sense that
wayne county 85 percent of the vote in
joe biden running ahead so we pull out
to the bigger map
and we look at it this way right ladies
and gentlemen this could be close to it
donald trump won those three he's
leading in pennsylvania right now i just
hope
he can pull this off just so people see
you see the map right now
i just turned off the states that we
have not called pennsylvania north
carolina
georgia alaska arizona and nevada the
key point is
all joe biden needs now to get to 270 is
this one
and this one and as we count the votes
throughout the day
he's leading in both of them that would
be the difference let's take a look at
those two
okay so let's get away from cnn because
they tend to be relatively litigious
let's see if anybody else is calling
michigan
um here's nate silver let's see a
thousand
uh group of votes that are still out
there so it's oh
let's briefly talk about er oh oh
actually let's listen you had kind of a
red shift among male votes in arizona
democrats sent their votes in early
gop votes came in later if you kind of
squint and look at the math
in a certain way it just might turn into
a tie for trump but
the problem is that biden over performs
the party registration numbers
in arizona because you have a lot of
ancestral john mccain republicans who
are now swing voters see a lot of
independents who are now
democrats in name only um so
so the question here guys is about
arizona the associated press has called
arizona now let me ask you guys
not everybody has called arizona
associated press has been perfect
um can you are you guys in agreement
that we should we go with arizona
because ap has called it and they've
been
perfect and have not had to go back on
anything
one person says no most people say yeah
that arizona is just in yeah i'm pretty
comfortable with that
so understanding that cnn has called
michigan
but the associated press has not
uh i don't believe abc uh has
let's see um north carolina has not
called it
and cbs has not called it cnn
has now called michigan if we give biden
michigan
just theoretically if biden gets
michigan
he now needs any other state to win
okay this would put joe biden at 264.
if nevada comes in
that means biden has got it if whoa hold
on a second
if pennsylvania comes in that means joe
biden has got it
if north carolina comes in
that means joe biden has got it and
if georgia were to happen although i
don't see it
although some people are telling me it
could uh that it's going to happen i am
told that decision
desk hq has also called michigan for
biden i'm pretty comfortable then if we
have a
if we have a michigan call from cnn and
from decision desk
i i think that i think that michigan's
done i think that michigan's done
of course the reaction from donald trump
immediately
file suit in michigan to stop the county
okay
something is happening at the trump
event we're expecting to hear from trump
very very soon
uh i think we have some kind of update
here
from nevada as we wait here
although nevada's secretary of state
said no further results would be
reported wednesday
in order to give breathing room to tally
remaining ballots
northern nevada's washoe county does
plan to announce an update
on wednesday okay
that's good we will keep an eye out for
that let me see if i can find us
some other stream for this trump event
because it's going to be completely
unhinged ladies and gentlemen
we are at 92 000 concurrent viewers on
youtube
this has never happened before we have
breached
100 000 live concurrent viewers in total
we have 8 000 people watching on twitch
we have 91 000
on youtube and another 3 000 on facebook
100
000 live viewers thank you to everybody
i ca i'm shocked by what's going on
i thought yesterday's stream would be by
far the best but
it is we are even ahead of that right
now
appreciate everybody being here with me
trump philadelphia let's see if we can
find this
another stream we are on the yahoo
finance event
there is a global news event
let me see what they have
if you have a message for me that you'd
like to get up on the screen
uh you can send it via super chat if
you're watching on youtube
or via twitch sub if you're watching on
twitch
i am really not finding any other
reliable streams here for this trump
event imagine if they cancel it because
they realize that
it's it's looking very bad i would be
interesting
interested
to see that um
yeah i'm not finding any if somebody can
tell me some other
uh youtube channel that has this trump
event i would love like to find it trump
press conference i'm just not seeing
anybody else carrying it live
just yahoo finance and presumably
presumably some of these others will uh
carry it live as well
although they've not oh god let's listen
to what chris christie's saying what the
result will be who knows
um but what we know is that we're not
asking i don't want people to
misunderstand
it's not saying through these lawsuits
don't count any more votes
leave it where it is what he's saying is
if you want
we don't want any more votes counted
until
we can have representatives there
watching to make sure the count is on
the up and up
and i think that would be something that
the biden campaign if they're being
reasonable
wouldn't disagree about okay a lot more
vote coming in today we expect more
coming in from michigan we've said more
votes coming in from pennsylvania and
probably the remaining votes
from arizona as okay i'm being told that
now um
it had that the ap has called michigan i
still don't see it on their map
i do see people telling me ap has called
michigan
not yet reflected on the map cnn has
called it we now have
michigan over on the um
on the biden side as we stand by
for what is now a black screen coming to
us from what was supposed to be
a major trump event they were going to
be brutally
explaining why everything is unfair
everywhere and trump really won
but right now they are just sending us a
black screen
we'll turn the audio up there so that we
are able to keep an
eye on that very very important
okay if you're just joining us
we are looking at the latest data coming
in
the big news over the last four hours is
that
joe biden has won wisconsin and
multiple networks have called michigan
for joe biden as well
okay that is the news we
don't have anything new from
pennsylvania other than the margin has
tightened in fact
let's get some updated news
still at 5.3 with 86 reporting you know
it's not totally clear to me that biden
will win
um he's got to start making up ground i
mean basically so
there's 14 to go and biden needs
5.3 so it means that
for every percentage of the vote that's
counted biden needs to close the gap by
about 0.4
that's like really rough math and
i don't know if that's possible but
they've got to count everything
in north carolina nothing new still
a 1.4 percent gap with 94 reporting
in georgia um still at 96 percent with
1.6
separating the candidates and then
nevada
nothing new although we are expecting
maybe a little bit more data maybe a
little bit more data coming out of
nevada
now the trump campaign event supposedly
has ended
i need you guys to help me figure this
out is is it did they cancel did they
change their mind once
did they cancel it because michigan was
called is that a possibility
um michigan now being called by nbc news
very very strong call
um
if anybody can tell me what is going on
with that event let me excuse me i'm
just going to look down and check my
twitter
from being able to get to that magic
number that he needs
one of the lovely features of the uh the
wall that we've been playing with i call
it the kornacki i got a cornacchio on my
laptop
once we get down to a certain number of
states it will tell you
how many paths to victory there are
and so based on the states that have
been claimed so far
based on the nbc news projections by our
math mathematically
huge joe biden has seven paths to
victory
president trump has three and there's
one circumstance under which they could
tie
lord jesus they would tie if joe biden
won
georgia and donald trump won everything
else they would be tied
and and we would we would need a hug
right around here because this race
would go on and on and on but
joe biden could win it with just
pennsylvania so that makes
what we're gonna hear from the trump
campaign what we've heard from them
today and what we will hear
even more essential they take georgia
north carolina joe biden wins
georgia actually georgia and pretty much
any of the other states that are
outstanding
okay also mark as you mentioned arizona
and nevada
is so guys i'm finding nothing about
whether the event has been uh canceled
that was yeah that guy's i i apologize
that was an old trump event from
september 3rd you don't worry you're not
missing anything
uh okay let's see i'm being sent a tweet
here
let me take a look at this tweet and see
what this is about
a state court in pennsylvania has
rejected a legal complaint brought by
republicans in pennsylvania
who objected that they were not given a
good enough chance to observe the
opening and sorting of ballots pete
williams reports
that's from seven minutes ago this may
explain
if indeed the event has been canceled
the trump event has been canceled
that may well be why um as at this point
it does not seem as though that event is
going to be happening
guys this is just wild this is
absolutely wild that this is what's
going on it really is incredible
um what a mess what an absolute mess
yahoo finance still live in philadelphia
i am being told okay maybe they have a
new event
let me maybe they ended one but they're
going to go to a new one
uh trump philadelphia
yahoo finance okay they are live again
all right so let's take a look at that
if they're doing it i definitely want to
cover it
oh okay they're still there wow all
right very good so that
is uh that is happening all right in
that case let's keep it here
i'm gonna refill my water and take a
just very brief break
and then um we can get back to this and
hopefully this event is going to start
all right so let's stand by
very strong then we'll go for a hundred
thousand on youtube if everybody doesn't
leave
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
uh
guys i want to remind you
i want to remind you that eric trump
kaylie
maganny and rudy giuliani they have
all called pennsylvania for themselves
okay they've said we've won we've won
pennsylvania
presumably this event is still scheduled
because you have a bunch of people
standing around
uh this is this is not live right okay
this is interesting
um so is it is this event how do we is
there an event is there an event that's
happening or not at this point i'm not
even really sure
uh let me take a look
i think it is not i think we can safely
say at this point it is not happening
trump
philadelphia
is anybody live trump campaign officials
speak
in philadelphia now this news stream
simply says this event has ended oh
i think now this is just rebroadcasting
the
yahoo finance trump makes statements as
ballots being counted live
that seems to be a non-starter
altogether
so that is not happening oh they move
the event
can somebody tell me where they have
moved the event to
and if somebody can tell me that i would
love to know that because i
at this point it's anyone's guess
it's anyone's guess what it is that is
going on here um
they've moved it to mars yeah that's
possibility uh the margin has narrowed
to 5.2 in pennsylvania let's look at
that we're watching pennsylvania really
really closely
now with 86 reporting the margin is down
to 5.2
over the last four percent of count of
counted ballots
the margin has been reduced from 6.9
to 4.2 i'm sorry
5.2 that is a
significantly significantly lower margin
okay people saying that the trump event
is on fox
news let's take a look at that fox news
live and see what we've got there
um fox news live
not seeing it there let me see how i can
do this
i should be able to get us a fox news
live i can probably pull this up
in a very particular way watch fox news
online on
air now and
fox news let's take a look here
for your guy or knock out enough votes
of the other guy to change the outcome
it's hard work it's challenging work
there's a road to victory for the trump
camp eighth but let's not have any
all right hold on a second here got it
under pre-final word john you great
catching up with
with you as well thank you guys very
very much we'll we'll see how
how this goes uh taking a look right now
i'm not at this
presser as it's starting guys it looks
like it is oh here we go
all right let's dip into this and see
what they oh my god this is insane who
is speaking there just some of the top
campaign officials
to meet with our legal teams oh this is
rich
um we've declared victory in
pennsylvania we're up by 400 000 votes
with 86 of the precincts
in 86 we have republican votes still
coming in from
trump country and the democrats know
that the only way that they could win
this election is to cheat in
pennsylvania
and we've seen it from day one we've
just count to 100 percent ballots and
drainage ditches
they're not letting our poll watchers
watch the polls they're not letting them
inside
there's video after video of them
passing out collateral material
and polling sites all over philadelphia
they're trying to cheat
they're trying to cheat they have three
by five printed big posters
in polling locations all over the city
saying to vote three by five
harris which is totally illegal they're
passing out flyers
the supervisors of elections we have
them on video certain ones wearing
literally biden harris face mess
in polling locations which is totally
legal
and now they won't let and we brought
one great gentleman here with us today
jeremy
who's a poll watcher down to the
convention center they won't even let
him watch
as they count the ballots they put them
behind a fence 40
50 yards away where they actually can't
see the counting happening
what guys this is fraud this is absolute
fraud we've seen it in philadelphia
before
they're trying to make a mockery of the
election of this country
hey how about we just count to 100 guys
votes in this state with 86
reported and plenty of red counties left
to go
plenty of red counties left to go we're
gonna win pennsylvania
but they're trying to cheat us out of it
because they know it's their only
path to victory does anyone understand
how they're cheating
so we came here today we met with all
our lawyers uh we are going to file suit
in pennsylvania against who we have to
do that is the last thing that we wanted
to do it's the last thing my father
wanted to do
but this is rampant corruption and it
can't happen
who's corrupt it's not fair this isn't
democracy and with that i want to pass
it off to the great
rudy giuliani who's really leading the
legal effort and uh you'll be hearing
from uh from rudy quite a bit
late he'll be giving an exclusive to a
reporter named tutar later today
it is it is very very sad that we're
here in
the city that's really the birthplace of
our democracy
and this is among one of the most
anti-democratic
things i've ever seen or encountered and
it's not just here in in phil
in philadelphia this is going on all
over the country
we have filed a lawsuit the lawsuit
actually required that when these
in ballots that you know are highly
suspicious anyway
yeah just by nature balloting has always
been considered the most prone to fraud
that's fraud the new york times when it
didn't apply
to candidate president trump this
wouldn't even be allowed on twitter
because it's this information
to observe the counting of the ballots
now observe means to any intelligent
person
right being able to look at it the way
it's interpreted by the
democrat crooked machine of
philadelphia is that the observers
can be 20 or 30 feet away
never able to see the ballot itself
never able to see if it was properly
postmarked
properly addressed properly signed on
the outside
all the things that often lead to
disqualification of ballots
or make it very easy to dump 50 000
totally fraudulent ballots
because they're not observed anybody
following this this went on for 20 hours
wow all of you thought there was some
kind of legitimate count going on here
in philadelphia it's like obamacare
illegitimate
so we went back to court and we went
before a democrat judge
no need to tell you what the result in
philadelphia is if you're before a
democrat judge
obviously a political hack who doesn't
know the meaning of the word observe
observed means to be able to look
not a single republican has been able to
look at any one of these male ballots
this is as convincing as obamacare or
they could be from the democratic
national committee joe biden could have
voted 50 times as far as we know what 5
000 times
this is dangerous
philadelphia unfortunately and would say
this about my own city has a reputation
for voter fraud
you have a reputation for dead people
voting and we're going to go look at
just how many dead people voted here
i didn't think we'd have to do that but
we will and you have a reputation for
people being bussed in from camden
voting here
imagine if after all this pennsylvania
doesn't matter but this goes way
beyond any of that and let me also add
this is poison this isn't happening just
here we have exactly the same lawsuit in
wisconsin
how perfect exactly the same thing
happened what a coincidence
wisconsin mysteriously at four o'clock
or three o'clock
in the morning about 120 000 ballots
appeared
oh here come these ballots right
well we have no idea if they really are
balanced we have no idea if they're
signed
if they're postmarked properly
do you have any reason to suspect
they're not thousand ballots
and they all got counted that's what we
do with ballots
now i'm informed by former congressman
sweeney who's been
we are considering amanda rudy giuliani
you might have noticed something
happened to
the electoral vote count for joe biden
our decision desk
has taken a look at michigan and
concluded joe biden has won in michigan
and gets the 16 electoral votes from oh
interrupting rudy screed to say biden's
getting another statement from
the presidency of the united states oh
that's perfect could do it
those electoral votes are still out
there when you know there's six
electoral votes there if he were to take
that statement oh that is just perfect
270 and he would be on his way to the
white house
now play of the game legal challenges
being mounted
as we speak by team trump let's go back
to rudy's paperwork
it's properly postmarked you make sure
you make sure that it's uh properly
addressed oh that is genius
you pass on it a number of these are
often challenged by the democrat
representative or the republican
representative
we never got a chance to look at a
single one of them
the gentleman here who was who did this
for us says about a hundred thousand
ballots went through that process
in the 20 plus hours in which they
wasted his time
by not allowing him to see a single
ballot
well that's 120 000 ballots that should
be
just be taken out of the account so you
want to look at that number
that 120 000 should come out and this is
an area in which biden is getting
60 70 percent of the vote i don't know
if
i i don't know this is going on any
other place
but it is going on in enough enough
frequency in wisconsin we've brought
suit
and now we'll have to look into three
other places what it says to me is this
is a concerted
effort to win of the crooks to run the
democrat party to get
people to vote for you big city machines
are crooked you know that 20 years 30
years 40 years 50 years 100 years of
one-party rule
leads to corruption of all kinds
voter fraud is one of the biggest
because that's how you keep your power
but we're not going to let them get away
with it they're not going to steal this
election
no they might win it people not steal
win
these people the elite they don't care
about the people
the people are the deplorables the
chumps
they're not important to president trump
he's the whole reason that he ran for
office
what and he's the whole reason for which
he's carrying on this campaign
so that your vote can mean something so
that your vote doesn't get wiped out by
a hundred thousand
i hope biden wins but this stuff sticks
around
for sheer entertainment value but it
becomes benign instead of so weaponized
continue the lawsuit here we're going to
bring a second one
and then we're going to bring a federal
lawsuit three lawsuits and we're going
to take a very good look at whether
we bring this nationally we certainly
are going to bring it here
through the entire every state yeah
right really exposed to corruption
national lawsuit there you go
but this is beyond anything i've ever
seen before who else could we assume
it comes when you think you have so much
power and you own the media
right that you can do anything you want
well sorry
we're going to fight for the people
we're going to vindicate
their right and the ultimate result is
president trump has won pennsylvania
right heard of a couch look at everybody
nodding in the background
talk about npcs what 80 plus percent
counted
and they haven't called it for you yet
they called california
the moment it came you know the polls
closed why do you think that is
you have to be ahead to win for a
republican
how many votes do we have to be ahead
400
000 is not enough it's satire with 80
plus percent
counted i think there's only 14 of the
vote to go
do you think we're stupid you think
we're fools no
you think your followers are stupid and
they do think you're fools
and that's why you get called deplorable
and chumps
it's over all right rudy giuliani
wrapping things up here i want to bring
your attention again
on the screen here what a day electoral
vote count why is he at 264.
what a day wow and others have all right
so that's from fox news there what it
what an event
that is unbelievable stuff truly
unbelievable
um i'm gonna need a little while to
recover
from that because that is just that is
something else
i'm being told that the pennsylvania gap
has shrunk again
now it is indeed down to just 5.1
um my rough math is that in order to
get back to tide joe biden essentially
needs to make up
.4 points for every percent reporting
that is my that's my rough estimate and
those
numbers are coming in nothing new in
north carolina
nothing new in georgia and nevada not
officially not giving us anything until
tomorrow but we were told that tonight
at 9 00 p.m i don't know if it's 9 pm
eastern 9 pm
nevada time which would be midnight east
we are maybe going to get some
information from washoe county
uh unbelievable you know i don't know if
biden's going to win
but i am just delighted to see people
like
eric trump and um
giuliani make complete and total fools
out of themselves i mean just
just what are they even talking about
what are they even talking about
um okay let me get an update on our new
member numbers
we whoa almost spilled an entire glass
of water we are now at
372 on membership which puts us 125
above the latest number and that
is 613 oh my god
which means we go 750 instead
and then on twitch we're at 1926
oh my god that's another 157
putting us at 770
the these numbers have to be illegal i
don't even know how how is this even
allowed
um i i i'm gonna have to talk to
somebody about whether this is even
legal
i don't think it from what i've read
it's not and what i've read it's not
um welcome if you are just joining us
give me three minutes to summarize
everything that has happened today um
welcome if you're watching on youtube
twitch
facebook we do have uh at this
point in time 104
000 people with us and i'm really really
glad
that every one of you is here the news
from today
is that the morning started
looking roughly like this in fact alaska
hasn't yet been given to donald trump
but i'm giving alaska to donald trump
the incredible news from today is that
first wisconsin
was called for uh former vice president
joseph r biden jr
by the way there's a hype train going
crazy right now
and michigan has now been called for
joseph r biden jr so
this is now sudden death for donald
trump
if donald trump loses nevada it is over
if donald trump loses pennsylvania it is
over
if donald trump loses north carolina it
is over
whoops and if donald trump loses georgia
it is also over now for me the most
likely of these
is still nevada but we've got to keep
counting the votes in pennsylvania the
latest update from pennsylvania
is that with 86 reporting donald trump's
lead has shrunk to just
5.1 to remind you we started the day
i don't know at 9 00 a.m where it was
but we started this stream
with pennsylvania about seven points
apart
6.9 and it is now down to 5.1
uh that's a reduction of 1.8 over 6.92
over twenty five that's at about
twenty two percent reduction in so just
while i've been streaming
trump's lead has been reduced in
pennsylvania by twenty two percent
people telling me to refresh uh okay i
think this updates automatically
i'm not seeing any anything different
here um still all looking just about
right the only diff oh
michigan has now gone from a one percent
lead to a 1.1 to 1.2
now a 1.3 lead in michigan so that is
expanding now what is the news from the
trump campaign
the trump campaign is suing everybody
chris christie looks like he's had
bad clams all of a sudden because it is
not looking good let's take a listen
fall behind if you're going to be in a
close race like this rob and i were
discussing this earlier
you always want to be the guy who can
you know uh be
fighting from ahead rather than fighting
from behind but i think there's a clear
strategy here i think arizona hasn't
been called
because arizona shouldn't be called the
ap has called arizona
and people don't really know what's
going to happen in arizona
none of the biden people feel confident
but you know what the trump people felt
confident in wisconsin last night
and then when milwaukee county hit all
of a sudden they were behind
i think it's close enough for wisconsin
for it to be appropriate to ask for a
recount
and they have and as far as the lawsuit
in michigan um you know
i think it's appropriate to say we want
to be able to watch these votes being
counted and apparently michigan law
allows for that
um and and so you of course would want
the votes to stop being counted
until the court rules and if the court
rules in your favor then you go in and
appropriately watch
those votes being counted and the same
thing should apply in pennsylvania so
you know i don't think the end game is
just watching the votes be counted i
think the idea is
you do that in order to buy yourself
time
to then come up with something else i
think that that's the approach
so indeed donald trump is filing a
lawsuit in michigan
rudy giuliani just told us that they're
filing a lawsuit
in philadelphia rudy giuliani told us
that they're going to fire file a second
lawsuit and then maybe a national
lawsuit
they're gonna sue every state it'll be
the biggest lawsuit anybody's ever seen
and that that is what is going on at
this point in time
um okay
i do want to you know what i think we
will do i i think that we're sort of
getting
most of the information that we're
expecting today
so what i would like to do is maybe open
the phone lines a little bit i want to
hear from a few of you guys
i did have a few memes it seems like an
inappropriate day for memes
but this is joseph r biden pacman
jr this is a blend of me and joseph r
biden jr that somebody made
it's a little bit it's a little bit
jarring when you look at it but
i don't know it just feels like we need
a little bit of a meme
so why not um this is me
wishing the american public was less
ignorant what if you could read
and then this i don't know if you saw my
election against jesse lee peterson
he got only alabama because that was his
home state
i i ran the table even the deep deep
south like mississippi
and louisiana georgia south carolina
it all went pacman so that was a really
really tough day
tough tough day for jessie lee peterson
so that is that
if you are just joining us though and
you're watching on youtube
please make sure that you like this
stream and also hit the subscribe button
it's free to subscribe
here is something you guys might find
absolutely hilarious let me see if i
have this
uh check this out yesterday okay
yesterday we had 1.4 million people
watch our youtube stream
and youtube says only 33 people
subscribed
now you might say if i had 80 000 people
watching all night
how is it that only 33 people subscribed
you guys
broke the subscribe button on youtube
this is something a lot of people don't
even know can happen
so many people hit subscribe during
yesterday's stream
that youtube cut it they pinched it off
and they said we need to evaluate each
one of they they want
they essentially are like doing the um
analogous thing to bringing in election
observers and saying
we need to verify each of these
subscribers my youtube rep today said
it was off the charts what happened
yesterday so anyway let's break that
button again hit that subscribe button i
don't know if twitch has a similar
mechanism but why not let's just let's
just do it there as well
and we did launch a brand new and i do
mean
absolutely brand new coupon code which
is
fresh start we're considering today a
fresh start no matter what happens
grab a membership at joinpakman.com use
the coupon
code fresh start for an illegal and
certainly immoral
70 off okay let's take some calls
i want to hear from you guys we take
calls via
discord davidpakman.com slash
discord when you get in there
click on waiting lobby waiting lobby
set your microphone set yourself to do
not disturb so that we're not hearing
discord
blinging all night because that's not
fun and then i want to hear from a few
people and then i'm going to run
i still you know i want to make sure i
get a run in and we've got to work on
tomorrow's show
and i think i'm cooking tonight so we we
have a lot of different things going on
i don't want to miss any of it but
i do want to hear from some of you guys
okay so davidpakman.com
discord uh i have a bunch of people who
are just calling me directly on discord
i'm not going to pick up on you
please stop doing it it's just annoying
it's really really annoying
uh we're go we have a process we go into
the waiting lobby we get ourselves
connected and let's hear from a few
people um
okay i want to hear from our caller in
pensacola florida i have many friends in
pensacola let's go first to pensacola
hey this is pensacola scott what's good
you know i have a friend scott in
pensacola
awesome i'm actually out on the disc
golf course trying to get some therapy
right now
i understand i was just curious
so the what will be the content
of the suits that donald trump is
putting out is he
asking for some sort of acting to be
taken or what does he want with these
suits
according to what chris it's a beautiful
question according to what chris
christie said
by the way were you are you watching the
stream on the disc golf course
i've uh got it in my pocket listening
that's incredible that's
that's a huge win in the battle of ideas
i think that the idea is
you claim that you need to stop counting
ballots until trump sends in the
observers he wants
and then i guess you resume counting the
ballots and they would i presumably try
to challenge a bunch of the ballots
that's i guess
but it's not really any clearer to me
than what crimes were committed in obama
gate
right yeah and i mean how successful do
you think he'll be with that
i don't think he's going to be
successful that's my best that's my
guess as of right now
even even with amy coney barrett and
everybody
on the supreme court i don't believe
it'll get to the supreme court i think
it's so stupid it won't get to the
supreme court i may eat my hat
but i don't think it'll get there gotcha
well thank you for your time i'll let
you
move on to the next one my pleasure okay
and uh how's the weather there on the on
the golf course
oh it's perfect about 75 degrees and low
humidity for florida
perfect weather perfect weather all
right there is a
um a warmly florida man
a florida man we can say checking in
from pensacola florida
let's go next there are just so many
people that want to chat today
and i want to try to hear from folks
from
all sorts of different places we want to
hear
from people with uh various different
priorities and things that they are
concerned with
let's go to uh
whoa things are just scrolling so
quickly i'm having trouble even picking
up on anybody
let me go to whoa this is just i
actually i literally can't pick up on
anybody because there's so many people
let's go to sergio from san diego
california sergio you were on
uh hello can you hear me yes i can hi
uh so good to talk to you i'm a new fan
so um nice to be here i'm trying to
multitask and
study for my quantum chemistry course
but um
i've been hoping that this would have
been a landslide election
um i know that's a big stretch but
i mean even now so definitely not but
even if biden does win yes how does it
feel
for you knowing that more than half
almost half
the country still supports trump after
the past four years i have been talking
about this for six months
and check out all of my clips about even
if trump loses trumpists still live here
60 million of them and actually closer
to 70 million of them
so that's that's a huge topic it's
disturbing
and it's disgusting and um
we i'm going to continue talking about
that but obviously
that's a disaster that we have to
contend with there and i don't have an
answer for you right now
yeah and um unfortunately as this
election
uh time started to roll around here in
san diego we've been seeing uh
waves of i guess trump trucks like
driving on by
in the areas i wouldn't expect we've
even had them in massachusetts in places
i wouldn't expect i mean they
it seems to be it's really a mind virus
that's spreading through these trucks
and it's uh it's it's uh
frightening to think that what they say
is true that there is this
i guess silent majority and
well it's not a majority i mean trump
you know most people voted biden
and biden's over 50 trump's under 50
so let's you know let's accurately
describe the problem but not go further
than it actually
goes yeah yeah definitely
yeah but uh it's trying to keep my
head up in these dire times absolutely
absolutely all right great to hear from
you uh hope things
continue well there let's pick up on
another caller
we're going to go to let's see
why don't we talk to uh
oh boy some some interesting stuff going
on here
hard to even make heads or tails out of
a lot of it
let's go to um
isaac from scotland isaac from scotland
you're on the air hello and david can
you hear me i can
right why are we i just uh just joined
the child i wasn't really expecting to
just to speak to the soonest lovely
lovely to speak to wow and well here we
are
yeah here we are indeed to you there's a
10 o'clock just now in edinburgh on the
east coast of scotland
right i've been watching with baited
breath the whole thing
unfolding it's just mental yeah mental
to see
it it really is and now let me ask you
as a foreigner
are you laughing at us because we have
65 million people
dumb enough to vote for trump or do you
pity us or are you just afraid like
what's your primary emotion
my uh my primary emotion is is sort of
shock
to tell you the truth it was this close
in the first place right pity
the number of sensible head people
in the united states of which there are
tens and tens of millions
and also uh
fear and anxiety like for the whole
world really yeah it is terrifying
we're scaring the the whole world
yeah no you no i hate to say it but you
really are in terms of
justifying authoritarian wannabes such
as trump
right and also sending the message in
terms of
global issues such as climate change and
international trade
right to say that this is our choice for
who to do that
is it's unreal from our perspective
david's to tell interested
i totally i hear the desperation and i
understand it listen just because i want
to get a scottish
perspective on this would you consider a
hot dog a sandwich
a hot dog a sandwich yeah
good question
oh this is almost like whether a taco a
taco
whatever you say is a sandwich i'd say
i'd say
yeah yeah it is the insofar as a sub
is a is a sandwich because the bread is
also joined at one side
right because it is on a hot dog it's
that sort of same shape so yeah
yeah now along that logic is a burrito a
sandwich
it's a burrito a sandwich no no i know
avery was a wrap
closed you know yeah interesting
interesting all right
very good well listen i i appreciate the
scottish perspective on these parent
issues of paramount importance i
i appreciate you taking my call and i
have one one last question if
if i may please i was wondering joe
biden recently said
that he believed that about 70 percent
of the billion votes remaining to be
counted
yeah you're you're breaking up but
you're saying joe biden says remaining
mail-in ballots because most of them oh
boy
we're losing you i'm gonna have to let
you go you've gone you've gone lo-fi
digital noise so i'm gonna have to let
you go but i appreciate the earlier
the earlier calls the questions let's go
to
aldo from peru let's go to aldo from
i don't believe we've ever had a call
from peru
hello
foreign
a
yeah i told him that he sounds like he's
inside of a cave
in spanish i told him that for people
who understood that we're going to have
to talk at some other time
we're having a connection issue there
let's go to elizabeth from pennsylvania
elizabeth from pennsylvania you're on
the air
hi can you hear me yes i can please set
discord to do not disturb
okay um so i
was just wondering um i we have been so
caught up in
what's going on with the election
results right now but earlier today my
partner and i were talking and we
realized
um what about the scenario where trump
loses
and then he immediately begins
campaigning
for the next cycle and in that process
continues to drum up
hatred and fear-mongering
what is that going to look like are we
prepared for that is anybody talking
about that but wait a second you're
saying trump loses the presidency but
then campaigns for senators and members
of the house for 2022 is what you're
saying
he begins kind of campaigning for 2024
so he continues being in the public eye
as president he continued as president
for 2024
yeah yeah well i think we would at least
get two and a half years off before i i
don't think that's something to worry
about at this point
you're coming through extremely loudly
are you using some kind of an amplifier
no i don't think so you're not okay no
people are just finding your connection
is extremely powerful as
far as an audio signal is concerned
thank you for taking my question all
right thanks elizabeth great to hear
from you
uh wow wow uh people all over the place
let's go to eric from mississippi eric
from mississippi
are on the air oh god
hi david hi
are you are you operating some kind of a
siren are
you at a lighthouse or no my mom
actually just started calling the phone
oh that was a phone okay yeah um
so one question i have for you is you
didn't just launch
a nuclear uh a submarine based missile
did you
oh not yet not dead okay good thank you
go ahead yeah okay
um yeah i have a lot of friends on the
left all over the country
a lot of things i'm hearing that's
concerning is like
they're talking about voter shame like
they are not participating in the
election right
and um any time you try to convince them
to go otherwise for no matter how severe
of trumpet is
they just say you're voter shaming me
okay and i don't have to
okay so i'm wondering what your take on
that sort of thing is
you know we've talked about voter
shaming given that the election just
ended i'm finding myself disinclined to
really figure out ways to respond to
that right now because
we're at the farthest possible point we
could be from needing to deal with that
again
i mean it doesn't mean we're not going
to need to deal with it again in 2022
but you know oftentimes those folks just
don't want to vote and it's not
there's nothing you can say they just
don't want to vote and they won't
they'll say anything
yeah so i wouldn't worry too much about
that
okay thanks david all right thank you
we're taking calls via discord
at davidpakman.com discord we'll take a
couple more
um we're going to go next to
uh where are we gonna go a lot of
international stuff
let's go to ashley from wales ashley are
you welsh
hello hello oh my god i'm sorry i wasn't
expecting it so quickly
oh i'm sorry i surprised you
um oh my gosh sorry um i wanted to ask
yes do you think donald trump
has any idea of the scale
of global warming or any of that type of
stuff
because i don't really think he does to
be honest he has no idea whatsoever
yeah i didn't think so yeah now
let me ask you as a welsh individual
when you see trump be so idiotic on
climate
do you laugh are you afraid because it
affects the whole planet
how do you see it to be honest
i have a bit of a laugh and a cry
[Music]
um yeah can i actually
have a little bit of an input on the
sandwich debate
oh please so in wales
we actually have this thing called a
chip putty okay
where what you do is you get one piece
of bread okay
um you put chips or fries as you guys
would call it in there
you put tomato sauce and then you'd fold
over
the bread and eat it that's called a
chipotle
so if i understand let me make sure i
understand let me make sure i understand
this
you're taking one piece of bread and
then you're putting
fries across the bread
yeah and then on top of that you're
putting what you called tomato sauce or
like marinara pasta sauce whatever
oh oh wait it's ketchup ketchup yeah we
call it tomato sauce yeah
oh my god so what do you call pasta
sauce
pasta sauce um well it's a bit of a mix
really some people just call it pasta
sauce
some people's tomato sauce and nobody
calls it ketchup because
it just feels more bougie so are you
saying that in
in wales tomato sauce could refer both
to ketchup or marinara
yeah i guess i am saying that and i now
that's strange isn't it
it to be fair yeah it is
okay all right but back to the sandwich
you got a piece of bread
french fries and ketchup and then you
roll it into a circle and eat it
yeah so you fold so you put like the
fries
on one half of the piece of bread yeah
and then you fold the other half over so
it's covering
it and that's basically a hot dog or
something like that but with chips and
bread
and that is a sandwich or it's not a
sandwich it's a sandwich that is a
sandwich
a chippati which is considered a
sandwich a chip sandwich
that very much sounds not like a
sandwich to me
yeah i mean you know that's just how
i've grown up
yeah i've learned to believe that that
is a sandwich i
i do think these are the types of
cultural differences that could
easily be bridged yeah i i saw someone
in the chat
say that sounds delish and yes it is i
just wanted to say that
uh people in the chat asking if you're
on any dating sites i think that's
inappropriate right that's not fair
oh gosh yeah okay um
don't answer that don't answer that i'm
telling you not do not answer that
question
uh okay listen it's been a pleasure and
uh
we will continue looking at the what did
you call it a chapati
uh a chip butty chip butty
yes okay but if you say it a bit quickly
is
okay good i'm getting loads of dms
oh my god okay just very last question
malt vinegar on fish and chips yes or no
um as long as you have it with salt
okay okay very good all right it's salt
and vinegar
all right thank you so much great to
hear from you thank you so much
okay take care uh all right guys we
couldn't possibly go out on a higher
note than that
so i want to thank everybody who joined
me uh
as far as final numbers go the gap in
pennsylvania remains
5.1 we likely won't know for days
and we are going to be back with you
listen at some point i don't even know
when or where or
things are just crazy right now it's
like the show never ends but before you
head out
if you're watching on youtube please hit
the subscribe button it's really
important to me that you do because then
we are uh uh whenever i go live you will
be notified if you're watching on twitch
please follow me we are just shy of 60
000 followers on twitch which would be
an incredible number for us
and of course if you're watching on
facebook hit that like button we'll be
back
very soon uh no no more coffee pictures
just coffee videos on my instagram right
now david.pakman always available
and i'll be back with everybody tomorrow
thank you